Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brittlaff und äh,
in schneller Folge eine neue Sendung und heute geht's mal nicht um Corona,
Heute geht's äh mal wieder um den Brexit, denn die letzte Sendung war am 19. Mai diesen Jahres und das äh ist jetzt schon, ja, fast ein halbes Jahr her.
Zeit mal wieder zusammenzufegen, was sich eigentlich getan hat in Großbritannien in Nordirland im Verhältnis zur EU und vor allem auch im Verhältnis zur Welt und ich begrüße erst mal den John John Worse, hallo.
Hallo wieder.
Genau, wir wir kichern jetzt schon. Das ist ja eigentlich alles so traurig ähm trotzdem irgendwie auch unterhaltsam auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise, oder.
Irgendwie ist es ein bisschen wie so ein Autounfaller auf der Autobahn, also ähm ja oder oder man blickt dahin, obwohl es so schrecklich ist ähm ja das ist wie den Brexit.
Wie geht's dir denn so persönlich damit? Ich meine, du bist ja nun,
Brite, bis auch Deutscher, ähm ich ja auch so. Äh was macht das so mit dir emotional? Ist es eher so egal, entfernt man sich davon? Tut es weh?
Das tut es irgendwie weh. Ähm ja irgendwie also meine eigene Zukunft ist,
nicht mehr in Großbritannien. Also das ist das ist ist betrifft mein alltägliches Leben nicht.
Aber das ist nicht mehr,
nur so Brexit und nicht dann so Großbritannien EU Beziehungen. Das ist so eine komplette Enthüllung,
des britischen Staates irgendwie geworden. Ähm und das Großbritannien,
steckt in so eine so eine sehr tiefe, politische Krise gerade, manche von den Wurzeln sind auch so vor Brexit
aber am die können wir vielleicht später debattieren. Aber wenn ich blicke nach Großbritannien was ist da gerade los? Also warum gibt's keine riesen Demonstrationen auf auf den Straßen? Okay vielleicht liegt es an Corona und Lockdowns und das sei eigentlich nicht geht, aber
alles, alles, alles entspricht keinen sage ich Westeuropäisch und demokratisch Normen mehr.
Ähm und.
Das ist, was mir dann so wirklich stört. Es geht nicht mehr um die Beziehung zwischen Großbritannien und die EU. Sondern ist es dann ein Gefahr für die EU, dass so am Rande der EU gibst?
So ein.
So ein Land hier genau mit so so tiefgehende demokratischen Probleme mehr. Wir haben Cop sechsundzwanzig in Glasgow gerade. Das kriegen wir auch nicht im Griff. Ja so auch die grundsätzliche logische Fragen. So.
Und das hat gar nichts mit Brexit zu tun, aber das ist das ist die das ist die Normalität.
Was funktioniert denn da nicht.
Also jetzt kam die die die Energieministerin aus Israel in den in den Fahrstuhl und das war nicht barrierefrei.
Entschuldigung. Ähm äh die haben das nicht barrierefrei gestartet. Äh also eine komplette Ehre oder oder man musste
buntenlang während eine Coronapandemie noch, ja? Also bei der bei bei dem Eingang zu dem Konferenzzentrum. Ja oder oder da ist Boris Johnson, er schläft ein in den Konferenzzentrum ohne Maske und sitzt neben den Nationalheld äh David
der 95 Jahre alt ist, ja also so Verrückte, irre Sachen und das ist einfach
normal, ja? Ähm und ähm und und wenn ich ihr versteht mich nicht falsch, ja also Deutschland ist kein politisches Paradies, aber,
irgendwie die grundsätzlichen Sachen funktionieren halbwegs noch. Und und das ist, was mir dann so total,
stört. So wie sehr.
Halbwegs normale Großbritannien ausmittelfristig, ja? Ähm und,
Und dann, wenn wir schauen, hätte diese diese diese
ein Einfluss auf die alltägliche politische Debatte in Großbritannien? Nein, nicht unbedingt, also die konzeptiven steigen in den Meinungsumfragen, so wie ist das unbedingt eine möglich, ja?
Ach so, das alles wird mit einem Blick von Deutschland aus nach Großbritannien. Ich sehe so aus, als ob alles schief läuft und.
Aber irgendwie die die Popularität von Johnston und die Konservativen bleibt unverändert. Also äh wie kann das sein.
Und ich ich habe mich mal seit einer Weile nicht mehr getroffen. Meine Autouniversitätsprofessor, so ein Professor, so moderne britische, politische äh Geschichte. Und wir haben mehrmals debattiert, was.
Wieso? Wie kann das sein, wenn wir blicken nach so den neuen also die Seiten von John Major zum Beispiel?
Dass Großbritannien steckte damals Anfang der 90er in eine tiefe, politische Krise, Korruptionskrise der Konservativen, Wirtschaftsproblemen, nach dem Austritt aus dem Exchange European Exchange Macinison.
Irgendwie das harte Auswirkungen. Also Laber kam zurück, jahrelang war Tony Player auch vor seinem Wahle 97. Meilenweit vor die Konservativen, die in den Meinungsumfragen
das ist jetzt nicht der Fall. Also, wie kann es sein, dass wenn ein Land.
So objektiv in einem europäischen Vergleich so schlecht regiert wird,
es keine Auswirkungen hat auf dem alltäglichen.
Diskussion irgendwie und in den Meinungsumfragen, ja? Ähm also das ist.
Das ist irgendwie erschreckend. Äh wie wie sieht Bridges Politik mittelfristig dann aus? Gibt's überhaupt,
Eine Möglichkeit, das Label mittelfristig, mittelfristig zurückkommen könnte. Ja? Und das ist dann im Hintergrund und das ist was mir so dann so wirklich stört. Es ist ja nicht mehr Brexit, also Großbritannien,
ist raus, also die formelle Prozederin sind vorbei. Aber.
Wie wie sieht Politik in Großbritannien in zwei Jahren oder in fünf Jahren aus? Also da da habe ich so viel Angst.
Ich meine, okay, was ist denn dann also was ist denn da kaputt beim Volk? Also ich meine, ist das eine reine.
Der Medien. Ich meine BBC und so weiter, äh die ganzen äh News Papper stehen ja extrem,
auch in der Kritik von so einer politischen, aufgeklärten Teil der
der Gesellschaft, der Linken, würde ich mal weitere sagen. Nur das scheint ja irgendwie nicht zu greifen. Ich will ja viele Sachen auch gar nicht berichtet. Also man traut sich ja auch immer noch nicht zu sagen
Brexit ist Schuld, ähm es wird immer drum herum geeiert. Äh ja, die Leute schauen sich jetzt schon irgendwie France äh die vor,
und weil sie da noch äh ordentliche Interviews bekommen und dann gehen wir ja sicherlich nachher noch drauf ein, wenn dann auch so Interviews mit Betroffenen kommen und so weiter, die werden dann zusammengeschnitten, diese Artikel, damit halt einfach die Brexit-Kritik nicht durchkommt. Das ist irgendwie ein totales,
peacement.
Auch sehr wichtig, dass Boris Johnson regiert,
Für, sagen wir so, für ein Pro-Brexit-Allianz der Wähler. Ja, also, irgendwie britisches Politik in die alltägliche Debatte.
Ist nicht mehr eine Frage von links, rechts oder liberal konservativ. Es ist diese.
Wählerallianz der Konservativen heutzutage ist ein Pro-Brexit-Allianz und das ist,
kein müssen wir sagen, kein logisches Allianz, weil was,
Können mittelfristig die Konservativen oder eine Ideologie der der sollte freien Märkte,
wirklich am ehemalige Industriemitarbeiter in einfach anbieten,
Und das ist auch ein Grund, warum irgendwie Brexit ist irgendwie vorbei, aber nie vorbei,
weil dieses Allianz aus ehemaligen Lebewähler in die Industrie stecken im Norden.
Und vorherige hauptsächlich ältere und sehr reiche konservative Wähler, dieses Wählerallianz ist für die Konservativen noch sehr wichtig,
Also hauptsächlich, diese Leute, die dann 20019 für Boris Johnson gewählt haben, wären noch bereit für Boris Johnsons noch heutzutage,
erneut zu wählen.
Und dann sehen wir, was äh wäre dann die Alternative? Was sagt dann Labour? Also Labour versucht diese Leute ehemalige Wähler,
zurückzugewinnen auf eine Seite. Aber auf der anderen Seite verliere dann möglicherweise Wähler,
an die Liberalen oder an den Grünen,
Weil dann besonders in Großstädten nun etwas jüngere Wähler sagen, he Moment mal, also so eine nach innen blickende Pro Brexit-Regierung haben wir schon mit den Konservativen. Also Labour ist dann keine Alternative.
Also das bedeutet jetzt, dass dieser traditionelle Links-Rechts-Dynamik, was Britisches Politik in dem kompletten Nachkrieg seid, geprägt hat.
Gilt nicht mehr und es gibt auch dann dieses Problematik mit weil dann Schottland kommt dann auch hinzu
weil es ist fast unmöglich für Label eine ein Mehrheit zu bilden, weil alle ehemalige Labour sitzen in Schottland
die die schottischen Nationisten.
Und an komme dann diese Gefahr, dass die Konservativen machen eine Darstellung während einem Unterhauswahlkampf ist dann okay, wenn ihr Label wählt, ihr kriegt eine Label-SMP-Regierung noch eine Unabhängigkeitsreferendung in Schottland
Also das bedeutet, dass Labelsposition hier ist so verdammt kompliziert. Also die kommen überhaupt aus dieser so Teufelskreis überhaupt nicht hin aus.
Ähm und einfach statt so ruhig sich in dem Moment mal. Wir machen eine ehrliche Diagnose. Was ist schiefgegangen? Es ist nicht das unbedingt, dass ein ich will,
nicht das Label seid. Wir wollen eine erneute EU-Beitritt. Also das ist das ist nicht auf dem Tisch.
Aber einfach eine ehrliche Analyse, hey Moment mal, eine engere wirtschaftliche Beziehung mit unser.
Engsten Nachbarn ja in der EU wäre sinnvoll. Aber.
Customs Union.
Customs Union, vielleicht ein Single Market, also Binnenmarkt Beitritt,
aber auch anderen Sachen, ja, nur letzte Woche ist ist die Großbritannien,
EU-Digital Covid City beigetreten und plötzlich auf einmal sind sind britische Impfpässe in 20 Länder dann zugelassen. Es gibt einige technischen Probleme den manche noch ja,
dem den Ball drin sind. Aber
wow, plötzlich alles auf einmal, ein äh so eine eine pragmatische Zusammenarbeit zwischen die EU und Großbritannien und plötzlich die Problemen sind ja gelöst.
Äh also Label ist überhaupt nicht in der Lage auch sowas zu machen und und bis man eine Opposition hat, wo man dann ehrlich
was die Regierung tut, ehrlich kritisieren kann. Kommt man nicht voran.
Und und Leben ist einfach so nervös. Und ich ich wie gesagt, ich wünsche kein pro-europäische Position von Labour. Ja das kann ich nicht erwarten,
aber einfach eine eine etwas pragmatische, realistische Darstellung von den jetzigen Problemen. Wäre schon was?
Ja? Hilft das in dem Meinungsumfragen? Keine Ahnung. Aber das machen zumindest.
Das Leben für die Regierung vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger, weil die komplette Opposition kommt von,
außerhalb des Parlaments kommt von Diskussionen in den Medien oder oder Talkshows oder so, ja, nicht unbedingt von.
Gut, dann äh,
Schauen wir doch mal, was sich jetzt eigentlich getan hat. Ich habe schon gesagt, wir haben uns im Mai unterhalten und der Stand war damals in etwa so. Man konnte jetzt die ersten Auswirkungen von dem tatsächlichen umgesetzten Brexit spüren.
Äh die erste Wirkung, die sich halt sehr schnell gezeigt hat, war, es gab einfach Probleme mit dem Handel. Darüber haben wir auch gesprochen, die neuen Regeln, das ganze Red Tape, wie das äh in Britannien so schön.
Ja ja.
Ne, also so äh der äh das war ja auch so ein Mythos, ne? Ja, wir müssen ja die Bürokratie äh abbauen, damit irgendwie der Handel besser fließen kann. Das Gegenteil ist.
Total, ja.
Das halt jetzt einfach für Großbritannien im Prinzip die Regeln gelten, die für alle Drittstaaten gelten. Ja. Wo der da ja auch in der,
in der Debatte äh in UK immer halt so getan wird als oh jetzt kommt die EU wieder mit neuen,
Maßnahmen und die wollen es ja einschränken und so weiter. So nee, äh das erstes wusstet ihr, dass vorher. Zweitens hat wart ihr wahrscheinlich sogar im Wesentlichen daran beteiligt, diese Regeln mal aufzustellen, weil ja.
Ja, aber aber das ist.
Das ist was mir hier so wirklich stört. Haben die Pro-Brexit mit Abgeordneten der der konservativen Partei? Haben die das wirklich?
Verstanden? Worum es geht, ja? Also da bin ich nicht 100 Prozent sicher, weil die.
Und auch diese diese verrückte Debatte im Dezember letztes Jahr, ja, so äh die die haben die mit dem kompletten Austrittsvertrag innerhalb von,
so eine Abstimmungstage und eine Debatte tag, dass die komplette Ding abgestimmt,
Und jetzt mal ein paar Monate nach. Moment mal. So, wir haben ja Schwierigkeiten, ja. Im Moment mal, wir haben alle das im Voraus schon gewarnt. Also wart ihr einfach,
blöd oder oder habt ihr haben die die Pro Brexit-Leute einfach keinen Bock zu verstehen, wie die Welt funktioniert. Ähm.
Man weiß ja nicht. Es ist einfach, dass die es ist Ignoranz oder ist das äh dass die,
die die wollen es irgendwie nicht kapieren, ja. Ähm also ja, also es gibt ja diese Regelungen,
aber dann zum Beispiel dann kam der der der ähm,
Vorsitzenden der der der Aufsichtsrat von Marxen Spencers. Ja, er taucht auch in den Medien. Das macht unser komplettes ähm äh Geschäft in in Frankreich.
Kaputt. Wir können unsere britischen Sandwiches nicht nach Frankreich exportieren. Ja, das wissen wir schon seit Jahren. So was taucht auf, ja? Also auch äh also wie wie wie kann so ein ein ein großes Unternehmen.
Einfach so blöd sein. Es sind nicht nur die Politiker, die so ja wir dachten, es könnte doch gehen. Nie, also,
Auch also ich ich,
ich habe auch ein anderes Beispiel. Also ich habe eine besondere Bewässerungssystem für für meinen Balkonpflanzen, kommt von einer britische Firma. Ja, super kleine Firma, 20 Mitarbeiter, die haben eine eine
Tisch der Firma in die Niederlande gegründet, um die EU EU Kunden zu beliefern. Das haben die aus Marx und Spences, also eins von den bekanntesten britischen Firmen.
So es sind nicht nur diese Probleme sind nicht nur auf die politische Ebene in Großbritannien auf Firmen,
sind was wussten wir nicht, ja. Also sorry,
was habt ihr in den letzten Jahren einfach getan? Ja, also ob ein Extroverst war die komplette Wirtschaftsstrategie der Firma. Ja ähm also das war.
Das ist ja äh und das bezieht sich ja übrigens auch auf den Finanzsektor, ja, wo ich mich ja auch immer gefragt habe, wo ich auch immer vorher noch erwartet habe, ne, also irgendwann werden die Banken kommen und sagen, äh.
Aber das ist ein bisschen anders. Die haben schrittweise seit Jahren immer mehr Mitarbeiter nach Amsterdam oder nach Paris oder nach Frankfurt geschickt. Es ist ja klar,
Für mich zumindest, in Großbritannien,
die so freundliche Beziehungen zwischen den Citylanden und die konservative Partei.
Gibt's ja seit einigen Jahren nicht mehr. Ja so die Beziehungen waren gar nicht so gut auch unter Theresa May, ja? Also und die die Banken, das ganze Finanzsektor, das wird in Großbritannien zur Zeit kaum debattiert.
Haben einfach Entscheidungen getroffen, die gehen manche über einige Mitarbeiter gehen schrittweise. Alles unter den Radar.
Aber das ist auch was, was mir so hier so wirklich stört oder oder oder beeindruckt. Ist.
In man kann.
In Deutschland so Problemen sehen mit diese so Lobby-Geschäft in Deutschland. Das Organisationen wie PDI oder Verdi oder diese diese sehr starken.
Automobilindu.
Interessenvertretung aller Arten.
Haben so einen Rieseneinfluss auf wie dieses Land regiert wird. Und diese Diskussionen finden in diversen Konferenzen und Diskussionsforen statt, aber man hat den Eindruck, dass.
Verbände werden so gehört irgendwie, vielleicht zu viel, aber diese Diskussionen laufen jeden Tag. Die Regierung,
in Deutschland treffe keine Entscheidungen komplett gegen den Interessen von Autoindustrien oder die Verbände der Verkehrs,
Industrien, sagen wir ja. Gucken wir so den.
British Retail consulting, also das ist so das das Dachverband für die die die Supermärkte oder den Road Holeger Servication, also Verband für die die ganze LKW Lieferkettenfirmen in Großbritannien,
Schreien öffentlich seit anderthalb Jahren.
Wir haben hier Probleme, wir haben nicht genug LKW-Fahrer, wir brauchen Notlösungen. Unser Lieferketten werden zusammenbrechen, sagen die öffentlich, ja?
Was ist das? Ja ist das das zeigt, dass dieser Organisationen werden nicht mehr,
vom Regierungsvertreten mitgehört. Ja, also besonders unter Boris Trons, also die,
das alles ging irgendwie so, ja? Oder den der ist auch lustig auf Twitter. Jane Brandon, also das heißt der Chef von den
cold cold Chain Chain heißt der auf Twitter. Der der Chef von den so ähm gekühlte Lieferketten, also für die Lieferung von von Fleisch und so. Und,
der hat monatelang über diese Problemen berichtet und hat den Eindruck einfach gekriegt, dass,
Regierungsvertrieben hören ihm und und anderen Industrieverbänden einfach nicht mehr. So.
Wenn ein politisches System so funktioniert, dass die Regierung überhaupt nicht in der Lage ist.
Solche Menschen such auch zu hören und die müssen öffentlich die Regierung dann kritisieren. Ja.
Was ist das dann für eine eine Region? In,
welche in den Interessen von wem wird Großbritannien zur Zeit regiert? Das ist nicht in den den alltäglichen Interessen von den Bürger
Weil die wollen ja Märchenbrot in den Supermärkten. Das ist nicht in den Interessen von den Supermärkten selbst oder von die die Firmen, die die in den Lieferketten tätig sind.
Großetanin wird in den Interessen von wem,
zur Zeit regiert. Ja, auch sehr einfachen Entscheidungen sind dann nicht getroffen, um.
Einfachen Sachen für alltägliche Menschen zu ermöglichen. Und.
Ganze ist dann einfach so enthüllt. Ja, also wenn wenn Firmen kommen zu der Regierung sein, hier, wir haben ein Problem, wir haben nicht genug LKW-Fahrer.
Eine normale Regierung sagt, okay, wir machen dann einen Plan. Wie finden wir Lösungen? Wie bilden wir mehr Leute aus? Wie kriegen wir mehr Leute von andere Länder?
Ein was für anderen Lösungen gibt es, keine Ahnung, mir Güte auf Boote, auf der Schiene, weiß ich nicht was. Meine Wittle, so eine eine Art,
Plan oder oder Notfallplan. Ja, die deutsche Regierung sagt, ja Pech, also ähm äh ja, findet ja da irgendeine Lösung. Und dann,
Ja und dann dann ein paar Monate danach ähm der Verkehrs ähm ähm Minister Seite. Ja wir wir bieten einige ähm ähm einige Wiesen mehr für für LKW-Fahrer Fahrer an. Aber das nur bis Weihnachten.
Und dann mit eine begrenzte Anzahl und die Bezahlung ist für diese Menschen, wenn die kommen aus anderen europäischen Länder, schon geringer als,
In was man heutzutage in Polen.
Steigen wir mal so ein bisschen in die Chronologie ein und äh das ist nämlich genau der Punkt. Die erste Krise nach den ersten kleinen Krisen, nachdem sich das alles erst mal nur so
gezeichnet hat und man das Gefühl hatte, okay, alles klar, da findet eine gewisse Disruption statt im Handel. Die Zahlen sind extrem eingebrochen, die Exporte äh von Großbritannien insgesamt sind total in Keller gegangen. Jetzt kann man auch mal bewusst in Großbritannien sagen, weil das gilt halt alles nicht.
Für Nordirland, zumindest nicht in dem selben Maße,
kommen wir dann später auch noch dazu. Diese LKW-Fahrerkrise, das ist ja etwas, was dann sich sehr schnell abgezeichnet hat und das ist ja schon gesagt, da wurde jahrelang vor gewarnt und ähm,
kommen ja dann auch mehrere Sachen zusammen und muss man halt immer sagen, so es gibt halt systemische Krisen in den Branchen, die gelten nicht nur dort. Dann gibt's natürlich immer den Einfluss der Pandemie,
dann gibt's immer noch mal die extra Sahnehäubchen, Brexit obendrauf und ich glaube, wo man das wunderbar sehen konnte, war genau diese LKW-Fahrerkrise. Das heißt, erstmal.
Brexit hat sich angedroht, das hat ja schon dazu geführt, dass eine ganze Menge Leute das Land auch verlassen haben. Einerseits, weil sie schon für sich klar gesehen haben, dass sie da keine,
drauf haben. Viele Leute sind ja dann auch einfach, weil die ganze Stimmung im Land äh so antieuropäisch wurde, auf einmal ja Ausländer äh feindlich.
Eine Menge Leute, insbesondere im akademischen Bereich, die da schnell äh abgedüst sind und gesagt haben, so macht euren Scheiß alleine irgendwie, das muss ich mir äh nicht geben. Ich kann auch woanders arbeiten. Ähm dann kam die Pandemie.
Und das hatte dann wiederum zur Folge, dass es ja gab ja dann so richtig so dieses oh oh Gott, so grad vor Weihnachten, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie alle schnell nach Hause, weil sonst kommen wir hier nicht mehr weg und wir wollen ja irgendwie bei unserer Familie sein, weil ist ja Pandemie und Krise und,
So, das führte dazu, dass halt in vielen Branchen das Personal weg war. Das,
die Zahlen nicht ganz genau, aber es war signifikant zehn, zwanzig Prozent ähteilweise in manchen Branchen und es betraf halt unter anderem auch diese LKW-Fahrer. Die waren dann irgendwie alle weg,
Pandemie zumindest, na ja, ich meine, vorbei ist es ja leider immer noch nicht, aber es ist sozusagen jetzt äh ne, man äh wollte dann eben die Wirtschaft wieder anfahren,
sind die alle nicht zurückgekommen, weil sie gesagt haben, ja nee, Brexit irgendwie brauche ich nicht. Wenn ich jetzt äh und auch, also selbst wenn man nicht für britische Unternehmen arbeitet,
es gab halt auch gar keine,
EU-basierten LKW-Fahrer mehr, die überhaupt nach Großbritannien reinfahren wollten, weil dadurch, dass der Export zusammengebrochen war, bedeutet das, dass sie dann halt in der Regel
einerseits ohnehin sehr lange brauchen, also sehr viel Zeit darauf verschwenden mussten auf diese Tour und außerdem in der Regel leer zurückfahren mussten
oder zumindest nicht voll ausgelastet, wodurch natürlich das Ganze auch nicht mehr so profitabel war. Und.
Am Ende bedeutete das, dass es eine Fehlstelle gab von, je nachdem welcher Quelle man jetzt glauben darf, sind es irgendwie bis zu 10tausend oder mehr, so.
Entschuldigung, bis zu 1hunderttausend LKW-Fahrer. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Und das wirft natürlich auch nochmal ein interessantes Licht äh auf diese Branche als solche, weil wir sehen jetzt auch, dass diese Problematik so,
gar nicht mal nur in Großbritannien, ist nur in Großbritannien, ist halt alles wie unter einer Lupe äh extrem vergrößert,
eben durch diese Problematik, erst haben sie alle weggeschickt, dann wollte keiner zurückkommen und äh niemand will jetzt mehr in diesem Bereich arbeiten.
Und zusätzlich, da werden wir dann wahrscheinlich noch häufiger drüber sprechen, hat auch diese Pandemie, diesen Effekt gehabt.
Auf viele Branchen, die schlecht bezahlt waren, dass die Leute so mal ein Jahr lang irgendwie raus waren oder auch nur ein paar Monate aus ihrem Job raus waren, andere Sachen gemacht haben und dann festgestellt haben.
Den den den scheiß Job irgendwie mit der schlechten Bezahlung, das brauche ich in meinem Leben auch irgendwie gar nicht. So und äh das alles zusammengerührt führte dann dazu,
Das hat keine LKW-Fahrer dauern. Das führte dazu, dass die Supermärkte nicht mehr beliefert werden konnten und auch halt, dass auch die,
Unternehmen ihre Teile nicht mehr bekamen, die konnten nicht mehr produzieren. Also es hatte auf einmal so einen äh Schneeballeffekt, der sich so schrittweise auf die ganze,
äh Wirtschaft in Großbritannien ausgewirkt hat und als erstes sichtbar wurde es dann in den Supermärkten, als dann die Regale leer wurden, ne.
Teilweise absurden äh Szenen in in Supermärkten, also nicht nur, dass die Regale leer waren, sondern dann wurden sie weiß ich, da war auf einmal so ein riesiges Regal alles voll mit Äpfeln, weil Äpfel waren da, aber sonst kein,
Gemüse. Und als dann irgendwann auch die Äpfel nicht mehr da waren, äh mittlerweile sind so Kartboard-Print-Outs.
In diesen Regalen so, also hier, hier könnten ihre Salate stehen.
So so Zeichen. Also.
Genau, also das ist ähm die Situation und die Situation ist ja auch nicht besser geworden, ne? Dann äh gab's wirst du schon angedeutet hast, diesen ja.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir irgendwas tun. Und ich hatte so den Eindruck, solange nur die Supermärkte schlecht beliefert waren, tat sich da noch gar nicht so viel, weil es auch so.
So eine lokale Wahrnehmung ist. Man geht in seinen Supermarkt, da ist irgendwas nicht da. Man merkt halt nicht, dass das alle betrifft,
aber diese Shortage von LKW-Fahrern führte dann dazu, dass irgendwann auch die Tankstellen nicht mehr beliefert werden konnten, was dann dazu führte, dass halt nicht genug Sprit da war, was dann dazu führte, dass halt.
Alles auf einmal stillstand und dann lange Schlangen vor der Tankstelle, das war natürlich dann irgendwie News worthy und
Ich glaube, da hat dann das erste Mal wirklich so eine allgemeine Wahrnehmung in Großbritannien eingesetzt. Oh, wir haben ein Problem.
Aber aber das hatte auch irgendwie auf die Regierung nicht unbedingt politischen Auswirkungen.
War ein bisschen es gibt genug Sprit, also bitte nicht direkt zur Tankstelle gehen, weil es wird ja gelöst. Ja, aber
ein Freund von mir der wohnt Nordisch von London, aber so einen kleinen Dorf auf dem Land. Die Kinder könnte eine Woche lang nicht mehr zur Schule gehen, weil es gar es gibt keinen Bus,
und er hatte kein Benzin. Also Social verrückte Sachen, ja, ähm nee, aber.
Nicht nur das, auch die Busfahrer waren teilweise gar nicht mehr verfügbar, weil die dann wiederum.
Angeheuert haben, weil um überhaupt LKW-Fahrer zu bekommen, wurden dann halt unter anderem dann auch mal die Gehälter erhöht und dann haben wir viele Busfahrer gesagt, LKW kann ja auch fahren.
Ja ja und dann und dann immer wenn es so eine Krise gibt in Großbritannien. Man ruft man ruft die Armee an, ja? Lass uns mal die Armee LKW-Fahrer verwenden, ja,
die Armee hat auch nicht so viele LKW-Fahrer, ja, weil die haben die ganzen Stellen auch
outgesourct und und und äh abgebaut in den letzten Jahren. Also das war auch dann keine besonders kluge Lösung.
Und es gehört ja auch ein bisschen mehr dazu als nur einen LKW zu fahren, um in diesem Transportbusiness äh unterwegs zu sein, ne?
Besonders mit beim Benzinmaster, ja, wo eine besondere Schein erforderlich ist und ja, ja. Ja, ja.
Und Ladung überhaupt also damit umgehen zu können und die ganzen Regeln zu kennen ja.
Und und aber natürlich auch also alle europäischen Länder haben diese Arten von Problemen, aber in Großbritannien kommen,
mehreren Problemen hinzu.
Großbritannien hat nicht genug LKW-Fahrer ausgebildet. Seit zwei Jahrzehnten. Also faktisch Großbritannien musste Arbeitskräfte aus anderen Ländern der EU importieren.
Eins. Punkt zwei.
Wegen die Grenzkontrollen bei der Ausreise aus Großbritannien und die Zeit, die erforderlich ist, um überhaupt mit ein Laster nach Frankreich einzufahren.
Viele Firmen haben dann eigentlich dann Dinge nach Großbritannien beliefert und fahren dann leer nach Frankreich zurück.
Punkt drei, Großbritannien nimmt nicht mehr an den sogenannten Carbotage teil. Das bedeutet, vorher
Ein LKW aus Deutschland für, sagen wir, mit Minimotoren von München nach Oxford.
So ein Laster könnte dann, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Waren von Oxfit nach Glasgow transportieren,
und verdammt von Glasgow nach Deutschland zurück. Also mache dann ein Pfad innerhalb von Großbritannien, aber voll,
Als Großbritannien außerhalb der EU war, war diese Zwischenetappe nicht mehr möglich. Also das bedeutet, dass ein statt Drei-Fahden mit dieser LKW und alle drei voll,
sind daraus dann zwei Fahrten mit nur einer Fahrt voll. Also das bedeutete dann Großbritannien hatte dann,
Und dann auch dann viel Punkt ist dann dieser Brexit Wieseregelungen, das das EU-Fahrer fühlten sich nicht mehr willkommen. Also das bedeutet also,
zusätzlich zu die LKW-Fahrerproblematik in aller anderen Länder der EU es gibt ja Problemen.
Hat Großbritannien dank die Linie des Landes noch mehr Problemen dazu.
Und ist es in die ganze Lieferketten nicht nur bei LKW-Fahrer, auch die Häfen in Großbritannien haben Riesenprobleme. Weil da fehlen Mitarbeiter, das bedeutet, dass die können die Schiffe nicht mehr entlaben.
Ja, es gibt so Riesenpyramiden von von Containers in Feex-Store, also eine nordöstlich von London, also von den Haupthäfen, weil die haben nicht nicht genug Mitarbeiter, um überhaupt die Containers
zu bewegen, ja? Also das bedeutet, das kommt dann auch hinzu zu diesen Ketten, Schnee.
Das ist ja ein äh generelles Problem, was wir derzeit weltweit sehen. Das ist auch noch eine Auswirkung aus äh,
Pandemie. Wir hatten die Pandemie, dann sind so die äh Transport ähm Kapazitäten, also die Kapazitäten waren da, aber die die tatsächlichen Bewegungen sind halt runtergegangen. Dann gab's noch diese Evergreen Geschichte im,
die hat natürlich auch nochmal so eine Auswirkung gehabt, weil das ist so ein,
so ein fein abgestimmtes Geflecht aus Terminverkehr, dass wenn das einmal durcheinander gerät und das passiert auch,
öfter mal, dass das so auseinander gerät und normalerweise,
nivelliert sich das dann in dem Moment wo die chinesischen Feiertage beginnen im Januar äh Februar, deren ich weiß,
ganz genau wie das heißt, aber so quasi was so bei uns zu Weihnachten ist, da sind dann mal die Fabriken zu, da wird dann mal nicht gearbeitet, da ist nicht so viel Produktion abzuliefern und normalerweise äh spielt sich das ein, aber mittlerweile sind die.
Die Auswirkungen davon so weitreichend, ja? Also man hat das ja auch in äh in den USA, haben sie genau dasselbe Problem, dass sie einfach dort den Container nicht weg
bekommen, dass ihr die Kapazität
nicht haben, die dort stehen zu lassen, sodass sie jetzt teilweise irgendwie schon äh ich glaube, da wurde jetzt gerade eine Regel geändert, dass wo normalerweise zwei übereinander gestapelt werden dürfen, dürfen jetzt vier und so weiter. Also es ist einfach äh alles der Versuch in irgendeiner Form der Situation noch,
Herr zu werden. Nur in Großbritannien ist es mal wieder besonders schwierig,
Weil eben da nochmal äh eine eine besondere akute Personalnot ist und das wohl auch schon dazu geführt hat, dass jetzt sehr viel Lieferungen dann nach Rotterdam äh ging und dann dort äh.
Braucht man dann noch mehr LKW-Fahrer, um die dann der Großbritannien so lieb.
Genau. Das funktioniert halt auch nicht, ne? Also das ist äh das ist so eine Katastrophe. Man man man kriegt sein,
Kopf äh gar nicht drum geregelt. Ich meine diese die du gerade angesprochen hast, soweit ich weiß, hat die ähm der Vertrag zwischen EU, also der Brexit-Vertrag zwischen EU und äh Großbritannien
der hat schon so eine limitierte Cabotage erlaubt, so zwei oder drei äh Fahrten, aber sie brauchen halt mehr um das.
Tatsächlich der Verkehrsminister hat dann diese diese Limitierung einfach aufgehoben und einfach gesagt, okay ist jetzt.
Innerhalb von einer Zeit von ein paar Wochen einfach wieder erlaubt. Ja, also aber irgendwie, das ist auch irgendwie lustig, weil der,
die die jetzige sagen wie so Lösungen haben alle genervt,
weil die Brexiteers an. Hey Moment mal, also wir verlieren mal wieder unsere Kontrolle,
und die Moment mache so, das ist nur ein kleinen Tropfen in den Ozeanen. Wer kommen nach Großbritannien für drei Monate zurück, um um überhaupt eine eine ein LKW äh zu fahren, der in dieser so ein Notfalllösung für für die
die Sprit
Tankers äh zu den Tankstellen. Und ich denke, es war sieben die haben 1000 Bewerbungen erwartet oder so und die haben 27 Bewerbungen äh.
Ja weil
weil sich alle die weil sich alle die Bäuche gehalten haben äh aufgrund dieses Angebots. Also wir müssen zwei Sachen da trennen, ne? Also ist ja dieses man kommt als EU-Fahrer nach Großbritannien, liefert dort was ab und dann darf man halt jetzt
unter Umständen, also ursprünglich zwei Fahrten machen. Jetzt darf man vielleicht beliebig viele Fahrten machen. Das ist aber sozusagen eine Ausnahme, die UK ausschließlich für EU-Fahrer macht. Die gibt es natürlich nicht anders herum für britische Fahrer.
So, das heißt, auch hier ist wieder dieser Effekt des Brexit. Jobs in UK,
gehen eigentlich weg, ja? Und äh werden in die EU übertragen. Genauso hatten wir das ja vorhin bei dem Beispiel mit den ganzen Niederlassungen. So viele Unternehmen sind jetzt gezwungen, Niederlassung in der EU zu gründen. Die Fluggesellschaften waren ja ganz früh dabei,
So, die haben das ja sofort kommen sehen, so mittlerweile, wenn man irgendwie easyJet fliegt, das war halt immer UK. Jetzt äh fliegt man normalerweise mit Easyjet äh Europa äh die allermeisten Flüge.
Ähm diese ganzen Niederlassungen führen natürlich dazu
dann eben auch Mitarbeiter dort arbeiten müssen in der EU, die dort Steuern zahlen und die dann sozusagen noch mehr Geld abziehen, mal ganz abgesehen von den ganzen Investitionen, die dort dann noch äh getätigt werden müssen, um das überhaupt zu,
ermöglichen. Also diese und dann dieses Angebot um die eigentliche shortage britischer Fahrer äh.
Zu senken. Das war so absurd und dann hast du ja schon gesagt, ne, das einzige Angebot war, na ja, komm doch mal für drei Monate.
Und dann vor Weihnachten müsst ihr dann aber wieder zurück sein, wo man sich auch fragt so, wer.
Jetzt seine Existenz auf, die ja irgendwo in Deutschland, Polen, wo auch immer äh hart rumänische Fahrer, um dann in UK zu sein,
alle wissen ja noch, wie sie das letzte Mal dort behandelt wurden,
Ja, wie sie äh während der Pandemie behandelt wurden, als sie auf der Autobahn festgesteckt haben und wie sie generell ja auch aufgenommen wurden in dem Land. Man man wird ja nicht mit offenen Namen empfangen, sondern man gilt als Ausländer und Europäer und überhaupt ganz was Böses. Das funktioniert halt also
alles überhaupt nicht. Mit anderen Worten, es ist auch derzeit nicht davon auszugehen, dass diese LKW-Krise sich nennenswert in irgendeiner Form,
verbessert oder? Also es gibt jetzt eigentlich überhaupt keinerlei Tendenz, dass sich irgendwas bessert daran.
Oder oder man man gewöhnt sich halbwegs daran.
Weniger Wirtschaftsleistung.
Ja ähm.
Arbeitslosen, weniger Steuereinnahme.
Nee, aber wenige also Arbeitslosigkeit steigt nicht zurzeit in Großbritannien.
Aber Steuererhöhungen gibt es schon, ja, also weil auch die Staat hat so viel Geld schon ausgegeben, um,
Notfalllösungen für diversen Problemen zu finden und Wirtschaftswachstum mittelfristig sieht nicht besonders gut in Großbritannien aus, aber zur Zeit ähm ähm,
an den Palmen, Arbeitslosigkeit steigt zur Zeit nicht.
Trotzdem geht die Wirtschaftsleistung nach unten und das bedeutet.
Oder oder geht nicht so schnell wieder auf, wie in anderen europäischen Ländern.
Ja gut, aber die Preise steigen halt auch relativ stark, weil natürlich der Aufwand für die Unternehmen sehr viel größer ist. Die müssen jetzt mehr zahlen für Transport, mehr zahlen für Lager, die haben längere Zeit.
Kommen wir, dann kommen, wie es der Tanz zu zu den frisch erfundene,
plus des Brexits. Ja, weil Großbritannien nicht mehr von Billigarbeitskräfte aus der EU abhängig ist. Das bedeutet, dass es werden
Lohnerhöhungen geben für britische Arbeiter. Aber es ist natürlich ein Problem, wenn die Lohnerhöhungen,
Was jetzt zur Zeit der Fall ist, nicht die höheren Preisen in den Läden abdecken, also die Preisen steigen schneller als die Löhne zur Zeit äh und in in den letzten in den letzten paar Monaten.
Ja, die Inflation frisst alles auf. Ja, genau. Mhm.
Anderer extrem betroffener Bereich ist ja die Landwirtschaft, der Agrarsektor. Das ähm hat mir, glaube ich, auch schon ein paar Mal angesprochen, dass das ja eigentlich so eine typische Auswirkung ist, weil das ja auch so ein Klassiker ist, dass eben, das gilt ja auch für Deutschland
ähm Spanien, viele andere Länder des Westens, dass halt hier äh,
immer wieder saisonaler Bedarf ist für Ernte, für Auslieferung für verschiedene äh Dinge
und ja, wie sieht's denn jetzt aus äh im Agrarsektor? Weil das ist ja jetzt ein echtes Problem. Auf der einen Seite, man kann nicht mehr so leicht exportieren, ja, also teilweise manche
Bereiche. Über Fischerei hat mir schon mal gesprochen. Die haben so richtig Probleme, weil die einfach überhaupt gar nicht die die Möglichkeit mehr äh haben, überhaupt was zu exportieren. Ähm andere Sektoren sind aber auch extrem betroffen.
So besonders die Fleischindustrie ist ist ist derzeit sehr hart betroffen. Ähm.
Die es fehlen Mitarbeiter in den Schlachthäusern, es fahren LKW-Fahrer, um überhaupt die Schweine zu den Schlachthäusern zu bringen.
Online Großbritannien ist in die verrückte Situation zur Zeit wo es es finden so Schweinekeulen statt,
statt die die ähm die Schweine zu den Schlachthöfe bringen. Also das bedeutet, dass es gibt,
ein höheres Bedarf von importiertes Fleisch in Großbritannien zur Zeit, weil Großbritannien kann die eigene,
Schweine zur Zeit nicht alle schlachten,
ähm auch in die Felder, ja so in in so Gemüse und Obst gibt's auch Schwierigkeiten, also die ernten,
also könnten nicht zu 100 Prozent so so geerntet werden,
wegen fehlender Arbeitskräften. Also die die dieses Sektor hat tiefgehende Probleme,
Verluste für die für die Landwirte, besonders im im Bereich der der Fleischindustrie. Ja. Ähm.
Auch Probleme des Großbritannien hat nicht genug Tierärzte ausgebildet und jedes Schlachthaus braucht ein Tierarzt für den Fall, dass irgendwas da schiefgeht. Das bedeutet, die die Anzahl an Stunden, die die Schlachthöfe Höfe,
offen bleiben könnten, war auch geringer. Ähm also ja, also ähm äh die die Situation ist ist natürlich für verdienen sehr schwierig.
Ähm und 80 Prozent der der Leute, die in dem Agrarwirtschaft arbeiten, die haben auch für den Austritt gestimmt.
Wollte ich gerade drauf hinaus. Das ist ja so eine klassische Zielgruppe, eigentlich der der Touris und,
das ist halt da fragt man sich halt wieder, wie kann diese Situation, die wir eingangs schon besprochen haben, da überhaupt sich halten. Ich meine, mittelfristig wird sich doch da die Stimmung ändern müssen, oder?
Also.
Angst vor Leber ist immer noch größer als äh die Realität von Torys.
Es herrscht es herrscht grad so eine Diskussion in Großbritannien.
Ein bisschen vorangetrieben von Leiber, es ist Brexit ist nicht Schuld.
Sondern diese Ausführung des Brexits. Ja, also die Revolution war die richtige, aber die haben das einfach schlecht ausgeführt.
Nein, also alle möglichen Brexits führen zu Problemen oder oder sorry,
alle politischen Akzeptablen Brexits, ja also raus aus äh der Zollunion und ein EU-Binnenmarkt führen zu Handelsschwierigkeiten. Also das bedeutet, die haben dann eine eine wirtschaftliche Auswirkung.
Aber es sei es recht grau die Debatte in Großbritannien, Brexit ist selbst nie schuld, nur dieses Brexit.
Ähm und das das stimmt ja nicht. Also alle,
politisch möglichen Brexits führen so genau so ein Ergebnis. Aber das ist genau was die Konservativen der Zeit,
als Argument so so so Vorschlagen oder voranbringen ist dann ja klar, also,
Es gibt ja Schwierigkeiten, aber Brexit selbst ist nie Schuld, also die böse EU ist Schuld.
Dass wenn ich genug Leute ausgebildet haben ist Schuld? Ja wer wer war an der Regierung diese Jahre aus niemandem nicht genug an? Äh LKW-Fahrer, die die Führerscheine gemacht haben, ja die Konservativen, aber das war David Kammön und anderen, also wir sind nicht schuld. Also
alle anderen sind immer schuld
Ja, also die die böse EU, die bösen Franzosen, die börsen Leute, die keine Ahnung, zu viele Grenzkontrollen machen bei der Einreise von Waren aus Großbritannien.
Die Regierung ist nie schuld.
Äh es gibt ja genug Sprit. Ja, also es ist es herrscht Panik an den Tankstellen und die die die Leute, die dann dieses ist die die in diese Schlange stehen,
Das ist deren Show. Das ist nicht unsere Schuld. Und das wirkt halbwegs.
Warum gibt's keine Riesenproteste auf britischen Straßen? Warum beherrscht kein Panik irgendwie?
Nö, es ist so, ja, wir haben Schwierigkeiten, wir müssen alle so zusammenarbeiten, damit alles gut läuft und die Regierung sagt, ja, wir werden mittelfristig eine Weltklasse Lieferkettentechnologien, Großbritannien haben, ja,
totaler Schwachsinn.
Es gab doch auch noch nie Demonstrationen in Großbritan.
Nee, es gab ja schon, ja. Also es gab Randalen in Großbritannien, ja, also die führte,
Die Hände vom. Ja, Riesenproteste. Ähm,
Oh oder ähm CND Riots, also amerikanische Atomwaffen in Großbritannien in der Achtziger, ja? Aber.
Wie wie kann.
Es war so halbwegs ein Witz für mich, ein ein in meine Diskussion auf auf soziale Kanäle. Jedes Mal, dass ich meinem meinem Rewe um die Ecke ging, in Neukölln
Ja, okay, was könnte ich heute nicht kriegen? Scheiße, es gab heute keine ähm Bio-Karotten, nur reguläre Karotten. Ja, ist auch so halt so ein bisschen so standing Joke geworden. Das war oh nee, das das richtige alkoholfreies Bier war heute aus, aber es stand sieben andere Sorten zur Verfügung.
Ähm aber irgendwie das ist nicht normal. Also aber was für alle anderen landet Europas,
einfach zu einer ernsthafte Diskussion führen könnte?
Für den Großbritannien sind nichts äh was sind die politischen Auswirkungen von von dieser diese ernsthafte Lage? Es gibt ja faktisch keine.
Und diese diese Konsequenzen, wenn.
Wenn ein Land schlecht regiert ist und das führt zu keinen ernsthaften politischen Konsequenzen.
Wo steckt deine politische Systeme, es steckt in meiner Meinung nach in eine sehr tiefgehende Krise. Wenn du weil auch die wenn ich rede mit Freunden, Familie, die sind ja.
Genervt, aber irgendwie haben null Hoffnung, dass man sie daraus.
Gute und ernsthafte Schlussfolgerungen. Oder oder das.
Ernsthafte Aue, es wird eine ernsthafte Auswirkungen auf den politischen Alltag. Ähm es gibt diese.
Hoffnungslosigkeit irgendwie unter Leute, die sagen wir so, niemals,
konservativ wählen werden, aber so die ehemaligen Remaines hauptsächlich oder ehemalige Labour oder Liberale oder Grüne Wähler, was tut man, um.
Diese Problemen zu beheben. Und wenn man so von Deutschen aus nach Großbritannien, also es ist sieht alles zum,
so verrückt und so bekloppt aus. Wie wie kann es so sein? Ja, aber irgendwie wenn man.
Wenn man das nicht versteht oder man kann einen anderen Standpunkt hat und man immer noch den Eindruck, ja the doing the best, die versuchen ja Lösungen unter schlechten und aus schwierigen Umständen zu finden.
Das fand ich schönste Meldung irgendwie.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Äh ja es ist wirklich äh absurd.
Äh die jüngste äh Krise, es gibt ja jetzt sozusagen wirklich jede Woche irgendwas Neues und das ist eigentlich auch ein interessantes Lehrstück über die,
Komplexität wirtschaftlicher Zusammenhänge, ne? Also gerade in dem Moment, wo Lieferketten auseinanderbrechen, macht man sich, glaube ich, nicht so richtig klar, dass das also wirklich ein Dominoeffekt ist, par excellence.
Irgendwas kann nicht geliefert werden, heißt, irgendwas ist nicht mehr verfügbar. Und wenn irgendwas nicht mehr verfügbar ist, dann kann das einfach sein, dass das so ein ganz ganz wichtiger Baustein ist, an dem
alles hängt, so ein Bottleneck irgendwie, dass äh dazu führt, dass einfach komplette Industrien auf einmal äh entweder ihre Leistungen einschränken müssen oder teilweise vielleicht auch überhaupt nicht mehr arbeiten können.
Ging es los mit Klärwerken in Großbritannien. Was ist da passiert?
Also es ist ja wie Alm in Großbritannien eine Mischung aus jahrzehntelang fehlende Investitionen.
Zweitens fehlende Arbeitskräfte und drittens, die Chemikalien, die man braucht für die Abwasserbearbeitung,
Viele davon kommen aus EU-Länder und es gibt gibt Lieferschwierigkeiten. Also das bedeutet, man musste dann unbehandeltes Abwasser in diversen Flüssen einfach rauspumpen,
Also es gab enormen äh oder Wasserqualitätsprobleme. In den letzten Wochen in Großbritannien. Und es gab dann nur die Regierung stand unter enormen Kritik.
Weil die haben so gesagt, okay, wir wollen eine dass die Regeln werden,
also die Strafen für die Abwässerfirmen, ja die die Kläranlage betreibenden Firmen sinken wir damit, dass dann mehr Unterhaltungsabwasser raus sind in den Flüssen abgepumpt werden können.
Ist ihr wichtig, weil wären Brexit, also das sind das Großbritannien muss nicht mehr die EU-Normen für Erbwässer ähm äh bearbeiten,
Bearbeitung nicht mehr respektieren, aber während dem Brexit eine Referendum war Michael Gof damals. Es wird keine Senkung von von Umweltstandards geben nach dem britischen Austritt.
Was passiert. Es gibt, oh, Senkung von Umweltstandards in Großbritannien nach dem Austritt.
Wie löst man so einen ein Problem? Es gab ein riesengroßes Aufschrei, äh auf soziale Medien gab's diverse Videos und Berichte und von Fotos von von
Gewässer voll mit Abwässer und was so, sorry und und.
Und dann die Regierung muss sein, Moment mal, okay, wir wir wollen das dann in Griff kriegen. Aber das war die Krise von letzter Woche. Also das bedeutet.
Ist dieses Problem in ja jetzt im Griff, wissen wir ja nicht so so ganz,
diese Woche haben wir anderen Krisen, also diese schlecht organisierte.
Twenty-six und die Corporate Krise mit einer konservativen Abgeordnete. Also das bedeutet, dass ein Krise schnell nach dem nach dem anderen, dass man weiß ja nicht,
haben die überhaupt das das andere Problem gelöst oder taucht dann ein ein neues Problem auf dem Agenda, einfach diese Woche dann ab. Ähm.
Schlangen vor Tankstellen gibt's immer noch.
Einige schon, aber nicht so schlimm wie wie zuvor.
Zu Beginn. Aha.
Ähm Lieferproblemen ja schon. Die sind auch ja ein bisschen regionabhängig, ja. Also es ist auch ja ein bisschen lustig, weil.
Vor dem wichtigsten Importhäfen für für für Benzin ist in Milfit Haven im Westen, also wo niemand wohnt. Also die Orten,
Die am nächsten zu den Importstellen sind, ja, so Wells im Südwesten, waren weniger betroffen aus London, was,
grundsätzlich ferne ist, von wo das Ganze importiert wird. Also das ist auch vielleicht ein Grund, warum diese Benzinkrise da stand
Standes länger und und öfter in den Schlagzeilen, weil die Leute, die in den Medienindustrien arbeiten, waren äh davon äh Herr zu betroffen.
Kann auch sein.
Aber diese Klärwerk-Problematik, die ist ja äh wirklich akut. Also es ist ja jetzt nicht nur, dass man davon gehört hat, sondern ich weiß auch von Messungen, die jetzt durchgeführt,
also es geht wirklich die Belastung äh der Küsten äh geht spürbar hoch, weil einfach irgendwie ja im Wesentlichen kann man sagen, die die kriegen ihre Scheiße nicht weg. So das ist äh.
Konservativen Stiegen drei Prozentpunkte, eine Meinungsumfang letzte Woche.
Ja also aber also das ist ja also wie.
Oh oder Wollen überhaupt.
Die die Konservativen diese Problemen überhaupt lösen. Was,
wäre erforderlich, diese Abwasserproblem überhaupt zu behebeln,
Ja? Eine reale Debatte in den Britischen und Haus. Ein Plan für die Sicherung, für die Importen von die benötigten Chemikalien.
Muss man auch sagen, eine,
verbesserte Bekämpfung der Coronapandemie, weil die Zahlen gehen so rasant auf in Großbritannien,
Das besonders Mitarbeiter, die junge Kinder haben, ja und die Kinder müssen dann mal wieder so home Schooling muss wieder eingeführt werden in viele Regionen, Großbritanniens. Also die Regierung,
kriecht auch das nicht im Griff, weil die sagen, ja es ist praktisch Krone ist vorbei, wir öffnen ja alles.
Aber dann auch mit Nachteile. Ja also das bedeutet, dass die.
Sie können keine einzelnen Elemente von dieser Krise dann beheben, weil.
Weil man kann kein einziges Teil beheben ohne die anderen Teilen auch halbwegs irgendwie.
Das das verrückteste war auch ja mitten in deine Benzinkrise. Die.
Die Strompreisen stiegen so rasant, dass die.
Die Gütezüge, die normal mit Strom, so Elektrolocks fahren, die müssen die Elektrolocks mit Dieselloks.
Ersetzen, weil die Stromkosten waren zu hoch. Also was bedeutet, das hat dann dann hat man mehr Benzin gebraucht, ja, weil auf der einen Seite man hat eine Stromkrise und als der anderen Zeit seine Benzinkrise, ja. Aber.
Die Regierung hä gibt den Eindruck, dass die nehmen diese ganze Reihe von Problemen einfach nicht ernst.
Und wir haben vielleicht das oder das eine andere Krise immer noch nicht hier heute debattiert. Das ist die,
so sagen wir so die politische Krise in nur die Irland. Ja? Was auch an Zusammenhang mit Brexit hat.
Lass uns aber noch mal kurz bei der Energie äh Krise vorher bleiben. Ähm weil das gehört ja jetzt im Prinzip in den Reigen noch mit dazu. Ja, also das ist äh auch äh ein globales Problem. Die
zum Beispiel steigen ja auch in Deutschland sehr stark. Äh die Strompreise werden dem in gewisser Hinsicht auch folgen müssen.
Aber auch das ist mal wieder in Großbritannien alles noch ein größeres Problem und auch das hat natürlich wieder ein bisschen was mit dem Brexit zu tun. Ähm,
die Gaspreise sind enorm gestiegen. Es gibt einen.
Gesetz in Großbritannien was so eine Deckelung der Preise macht. Nur diese Deckelung
ist im Prinzip nur Pear Company, das heißt in dem Moment, wo das Unternehmen pleite geht, müssen sich Leute neue Verträge suchen und neue Verträge sind dann eben,
von dieser Deckelung dann sozusagen nicht äh begrenzt und das,
findet jetzt auch statt, weil man hatte halt einen deregulierten Markt, in dem es sehr viele Billiganbieter gab, die da reingegangen sind und die Marktdynamik gemacht haben, das haben wir ja hier auch, die aber jetzt sozusagen mit ihren
mit ihrer Deckelung auf der einen Seite und den stark ansteigenden Einkaufspreisen auf der anderen Seite einfach nicht mehr äh profitabel arbeiten konnten und dann eben insolvent geworden sind. Was dazu führt, dass sehr viele Leute jetzt
äh quasi sich neue Verträge suchen müssten, weil ihr Anbieter nicht mehr da ist und das halt nur zu sehr viel höheren Preisen. Und
eigentlich ist ja aber Großbritannien an das EU-Energiesystem angeschlossen gewesen, aber auch das ist mit dem Brexit ja verloren gegangen.
Ja und Großbritannien hat die Gaslagerungskapazitäten,
seit Jahrzehnten abgebaut. Bei Großbädern hast du gesagt, ja okay, wir können immer noch genug ausreichend Gas von der EU importieren. Ja,
so Großbritannien hat in einen europäischen Vergleich nur genug Lagerung für denke ich ist es drei oder vier Tagen.
Gas kann Großbritannien lagern. Die Situation in Deutschland ist Deutschland hat quasi Themen für sechzig Tagen oder so und Frankreich hundertachtzig irgendwas, also enorm viel. Okay, die Gasverbraucher in Frankreich ist ein bisschen geringer, aber ein Grund,
Ich habe vor 15 Jahren im Bereich der Energiemärkte in Großbritannien, als Beamte gearbeitet. Und damals die Begründung, warum baut Großbritannien,
keinen Gaswagerungskapazitäten? Ja, wir sind in ein EU-Energiemarkt und im Falle, dass es Engpässe gibt. Ja, es ist ja eine EU-Energie-Markt, kein Problem. Wir importieren mehr von der EU.
Also sorry, ihr seid jetzt raus. Also,
das bedeutet das, man muss dann Verantwortung für so was übernehmen. Gab's eine ernsthafte Debatte ohne irgendwas in Großbritannien in Momenten? Also wenn es wenn so eine Energieprobleme auftaucht,
Harn hat Großbritannien dann investiert, um überhaupt diese Probleme zu lösen. Nein, natürlich nicht, weil das wäre das wäre.
Es wäre da nötig, die Kosten des Brexits dann einfach zu akzeptieren und das hat die das haben die Briten nicht akzeptiert und die britische Regierung nicht,
weil es gibt ja Verantwortung oder,
Bedeutet manchmal Kosten und Investitionen. Und Großbritannien ist zur Zeit dann Schuld. Und dann,
Finanzminister Sunark, der ist okay, wir müssen dann etwas für die Bürger dann tun, damit die dann nicht enorm hören ähm äh ähm äh Strompreisen bezahlen müssen. Also das bedeutet, dass die die staatliche Verschuldung,
dann noch entsprechend höher, dann kommen dann in dem in dem jährlichen Haushalt letzte Woche, dann Steuererhöhung, Erhöhung,
um diese Kosten dann abzudecken, ja? Und das unter eine Konservative, wo Boris Johnson sagt, ja so, wir sind die so Party?
Und was hält dann in den ja sorry, aber Label, die sind immer für Steuererhöhungen. Also wer hat dann Steuer so deutlich erhört in Großbritannien? Jetzt letzte Woche. Die Konservativen wegen
Brexit auf eine Seite und eine und ein fehlhafte Industriepolitik äh oder Energiepolitik,
auch dazu seit ein Jahrzehnt.
Welche Steuern sind da erhöht worden.
Die haben den sogenannten ähm ähm also das ist es ist es ist wie ein Einkommen. Funktioniert wie ein Einkommenssteuer. Also es ist ja auf alle.
Ja, also auch das äh kein schöner äh Bereich, denn äh,
gab's ja und das hängt ja auch so ein bisschen dann auch mit dieser Energiekrise auch noch ein bisschen zusammen, einen speziellen Streit
mit äh Frankreich, ja und generell kann man vielleicht das mal erweitern auf die ähm den Streit quasi, der sich überhaupt mit der EU so abspiel,
man hat immer noch den Eindruck, die EU hält sich immer noch sehr zurück so. Man äh
nimmt an dieser ganzen Debatte eigentlich nicht teil, während halt in Großbritannien auch medial immer wieder äh auf Europa eingeschlagen wird und irgendwie äh alle möglichen Ankündigungen gemacht werden, was man jetzt irgendwie äh tun und lassen und und kündigen.
Äh könnte.
Atmet man in Brüssel einfach langsam und versucht sich nicht aus der Spur zu bringen. Das ist in Frankreich ein bisschen anders
da gibt es eben diesen Konflikt im Rahmen der
Fischereilizenzen im Brexit-Vertrag ist geregelt gewesen, dass Großbritannien, französischen Fischern, die eine bestimmte Zeit äh schon in Gewässern gefischt haben, Lizenzen
ähm geben muss, um es äh insbesondere eben im Bereich um die Inseln äh.
Äh denen diese Lizenzen zu geben. Das hat auch äh weitgehend stattgefunden mit der Ausnahme von 20 oder weiß nicht
hundert äh also ein bestimmter Teil zehn, zwanzig Prozent haben halt einfach keine Lizenz bekommen. Das führt ja dann zu einer ganzen Menge Streik und das ist natürlich dann auch in Frankreich, jetzt wo es da auch auf die Wahlen zugeht und,
nicht gerade besonders gut da steht. Ein Politikum, es gab dann
die Ankündigung von Fischern, also dass sie dann irgendwie da die Häfen, die britischen Häfen äh äh auf Jersey besetzen und so weiter oder dass die britischen äh Fischer nicht mehr die Häfen in äh Frankreich ähm,
anlaufen lassen dürften und so weiter. Ähm ja und äh das eskalierte jetzt teilweise äh zumindest verbal hoch mit so Androhungen wie dann schicken wir euch halt einfach keinen Strom mehr.
Ja oder wir führen noch strengere Kontrollen ein für für Exporte aus Großbritannien. Also die Situation ist,
etwas milder geworden gestern. Es gab ein Treffen zwischen David Forst und und Clement Boom, der der Europaminister Frankreich. Ja, wir finden pragmatische Lösungen, aber wir sind noch,
so weit voneinander irgendwie. Aber.
Beiden braucht Frankreich dieses Streit nicht unbedingt. Großbritannien braucht diese Arten von drei Punkten noch.
Weil das hilft in Großbritannien aus seiner Art.
So Kommunikationsstrategie, also wenn Brexit nicht wirkt, alle anderen sind ja schuld, also Brexit war schon,
ein ein sehr sehr schwierig für die ganze britische Fischereiindustrie, nicht besonders die mit Booten, sondern Inland-Fischeries, also so so ähm ähm wie soll man das auf Deutsch Fisch ja ähm ähm.
So Lachszucht et cetera.
Ja, genau. Ähm also das bedeutet, dass.
Was ich ich denke, dass die EU kapiert hat, aber aber weiß ja nicht, wie könnte man am besten dagegen so agieren, ist.
Großbritannien will kein so stabiles Brexit. Ein Streit,
ist immer nötig für die britische Regierung. Ja, obwohl es so absurd klingt, ja klar, wir wollen eine Lösung für Fischerei-Listenzenzenzenzen, wir wollen eine Lösung für weiß ich nicht was, Exporten von Marx Inspences Samuels.
Ja für sagen wir so die Bürger oder einzelnen Firmen oder oder oder damit Lieferketten zusammenhalten ja dann brauchen wir dann Lösungen. Aber in die alltägliche Kommunikation.
In die besonders in dem Britischen Boulevardzeitungen. Das ist nicht erforderlich
Ein Streit mit den Franzosen zu Fischereilizenzen ist hilfreich. Schau mal, wie böse die die die Franzosen sind, die die respektieren ja die die Regeln nicht.
Die ähm die wollen uns keinen Sturm beliefern und so weiter. Also es geht so ins. Ja, manchmal ist es heftiger, dann die kommen dann werden dann ein bisschen pragmatischer. Dann dann
besonders David dann noch was in die in die Diskussion,
Ähm und so geht es geht es einfach weiter. Also wird Frankreich jetzt die Strom,
Großbritannien kein Sturm mehr beliefern. Kurzfristig nein, also alles wird weiterhin laufen. Mittelfristig.
Ich habe ja Angst, weil seit dem Sommer.
David Frost, der Brexit-Minister Großbritanniens, hat öfter gesagt, die.
Des Traden Cooperment ähm mit zwischen Großbritannien und die EU und den sogenannten Noven Irish Protokoll, die müssen neu verhandelt werden.
Was die diese Verträge stellen so für Großbritannien so tiefgehende Problemen dar.
Dass die Bussen geendet werden. Ja, einfach mal.
Brexit das ist so komplette Brexit juristisch Lösung kann mittelfristig einfach nicht so bleiben.
Das führte natürlich zu einen heftigen Kritik. Hey Moment mal, wer hat das verhandelt und wer hat das unterschrieben? Ja, David Forst, ja und Boris Johnson.
Zeitungen, so kommt das nicht rüber, ja? So einfach mal zu sagen, hier Moment mal, wir haben einen Fehler gemacht, wir wollen was anderes. Sowas kommen dann in Brüssel vielleicht nicht gut an, sondern würde nicht.
Plötzlich abgelehnt. Aber was was wir dann sehen ist, die Leute, die das verhandelt haben.
Die akzeptieren ja nicht die Auswirkungen von was die selbst unterschrieben haben.
Und das führt dann zu dieser Absurdesituation, wo Großbritannien sein, im Moment mal so die die EU sei böse, weil die machen, was wir unterschrieben haben, faktisch.
Und das ist, was wir sehen mit mit die Situation, mit mit Jesus-Streit um den Fischereipolitik und das ist, was wir auch sehen, besonders,
ähm äh mit mit diese ganze Diskussion dann in in Nordirland. Ähm und,
niemanden kann David Forst oder Boris Johnson und und Druck setzen, ja, weil
Mitglied des also des ist dann nie in dem House of ein so Brexit question time es ist nicht erlaubt weil er,
Nordsitzen nicht kommend.
Also um's äh vielleicht nochmal gesagt zu haben, für Leute, die das nicht ganz aufm Zeiger haben, House of Comments, ist quasi wie unser Bundestag, soll das eigentliche Parlament, was die Gesetze beschließt, House of Lource ist so diese oberen Karma nicht wirklich vergleichbar mit dem Bundesrat, aber halt so.
Nominiert, nicht gewählt, ja. Ähm äh er gibt relativ wenig Interviews, wenn er wenn er etwas schreibt, er schreibt das in den in den Zeitungen, die beliebt sind von den konservativen, besonders der David. So das bedeutet es.
Und jedes Mal wenn es strittig wird, die Briten werfen.
Noch was oder finde noch ein Problem und.
Das Hauptproblem der Briten zur Zeit ist.
Die Rolle der europäische Gerichtshof in Nordirland.
Ja? Also dieses Problem die haben das nie nie nie erläutert,
oder oder nie ernst erläutet oder öffentlich erläutet, wären die Brexit-Verhandlungen selbst. Und das ist jetzt für für David Frost ein riesiges Problem.
Obwohl wir wissen, dass das Fürth in Nordirland nicht zu ernsthaften realen Problemen da vor Ort. Ja also die machen dann,
einen Ideologischen, halbwegs juristischen Streit, weil die wollen halt einen Streit.
Mit Brüssel. Also.
Geht gar nicht darum, worum gestritten wird. Es geht darum, dass es Streit gibt.
Und man muss irgendwas finden, wo man streiken kann ohne möglichen Brändchen Auswirkungen zu haben auf.
Sagen wir grob englische Wähler.
Und was ist dann dann am besten? Ja, nur die Irland. Wir machen einen Streit um nur in Irland. Niemand wählt für die Konservativen sowieso dort, ja? Es droht dann.
Eine Blamage für für äh notirischen Juniisten bei den Parlamentswahlen in Nordirland, Mai nächstes Jahr schon. Weil.
Also den.
Also die Unionisten sind sozusagen die in Nordirland, die ja tendenziell sich eher UK führen, ne.
Die wollen das Norian. Es ist noch Teil der von Großbritannien und die sind die sind ähm äh protestantisch.
Also, die die UP.
Hat derzeit äh der Rolle der First Minister Nordirland, so soll es eine Art Premierminister Nordirland, weil diese diesen Possen.
Geht an den größten Parteinotirland und das war jahrelang die UP, also sehr konservativ und auch weil die traditionell eine Allianz hat mit den Konservativen,
auch pro Brexit.
Weil die hauptsächlich gegen also jahrzehntelang gegen Irland und gegen Dublin waren. Also wir sind für ein starkes souveränes Großbritannien so in der Art.
Genau, genau, die haben die der Regierung von Theresa May unterstützt. Was jetzt der Fall ist.
Ist, wenn wir sehen, was in der Realität in Not Irland fucktisch passiert.
Ist, es gibt eine tiefere Integration,
von der Wirtschaft Nordirlands mit dem Wirtschaft Irland. Es gab,
keine Benzinlieferungsproblemen in,
Nordirland. Also es ist keine Milkshakes gab in McDonald's in England und Schottland im Sommer. Es gab ja Milkshakes noch in die in die Filialen in Nordirland, weil die Griechen dann alles das über Dublin,
So das bedeutet, dass diese Brexit-Lösung führt zu einer noch tiefgehender,
wirtschaftliche Integration Irlands. Also nur die Irland mit den Republik-Irland. Und das bedeutet.
Politische Schwierigkeit.
Für notirischen Junioristen, weil die sehen, hey Moment mal, das wollen wir nicht, weil wenn wirtschaftlich ihr Land noch vereinte wird.
Führt für uns zu politischen Problemen. Also die Juniisten setzen London durch und sagen, hey Moment mal.
Wir brauchen Änderungen des notirischen Protokolls, damit dann zum Beispiel die die britische,
Ähm Supermarkt die haben die Filialen in Nordirland aus England beliefert mit LKWs.
Das ging ja nicht so einfach wegen die anderen Kontrollsystemen und und ähm weil weil nur die Irland gehört noch zu den europäischen Binnenmarkt, faktisch dank dem notirischen Protokoll.
Also Protokoll ist der Teil des der Brexit-Verträge, der halt diese spezifische Situation in Nordirland regelt, genau. Und äh das ist das, was damit gemeint.
Ja genau. Ähm also und dann Änderungen, es gab verrückte Streit zu ähm ähm was auf Etike,
in Not irischen Supermärkten steht, dass die die die Brexit Traditionalisten in Großbritannien die sind für die Wiedereinführung von von Peins und und äh und so ja.
Übrigens auch nie also die ja immer schon galten.
Ja genau, aber man muss.
Immer noch machen.
Genau, am man man musste hinzufügen Grows und so weiter, ja?
Und das ist dann noch Pflicht in Nordirland. Das Drums muss noch auf dem Etikett stehen. Das ist nicht akzeptabel in Nordirland, weil auch die Nordiren wollen den Fund zurück. Äh es war eine verrückte Ehre, ja.
Ich ich bin so aus diese so Desmo-Generation in Großbritannien. Ich habe ja keine Ahnung, wie viele es in ein in ein.
Stones.
Ja Mama, ja oder sowas, ja, aber meine Mutter schon, ja, aber äh keine Ahnung. Wenn ich lese an den alten Kochbuch oder so, ey, keine Ahnung.
Ja, da musst du musst du eine Fortnite drüber nachdenken.
Ja genau ähm,
Aber so eine so so eine verrückte Situation, aber aber das führt natürlich zu einer reale Spaltung in Nordirland. Also sagen wir,
pragmatische Junioristen. Ja, also Leute, die traditionell für die UP oder uninistische Parteien gewährt haben. Sehen im Moment mal. Also, wenn unsere Supermärkte aus,
Dublin beliefert werden können. Wir haben die wirtschaftlichen Probleme in Nordirland nie, was Großbritannien hat.
Es geht ums wirtschaftliche Ordnung. Okay, vielleicht lohnt es sich dann nicht mehr für die die die Saison,
Brexit Idioten von den UPI. Wir wählen stattdessen für the Lions Party, also das ist eine unabhängige politische Partei in in in Nordirland.
Ähm wir wählen stattdessen einen unabhängige politische Partei, die pragmatischen Lösungen für unsere für unser Teil von Großbritannien dann sucht,
Und das bedeutet dann den die Partei, die dann total davon profitieren könnte,
wäre dann ja also die Nationisten, die wollen ein verrenktes Irland. Und die könnten nach der Wahl nächstes Jahr dann größtes Partei in den nordillirischen Assem Leadern werden. Also das.
Premierminister stellen.
Dann die Premierminister stellen und das wäre dann eine Katastrophe für die Juniisten und auch eine Katastrophe für London. Und das ist dann den Hintergrund zu dieses Spiel, um Nordirland gerade, weil man also wir haben.
Boris Johnson, die Konservativen, die haben so einen Brexit-Deal.
Unterschrieben 2019 in den Interessen von englische Wähler und englische Brexit-Wähler und und für die in den Interessen von von den Konservativen.
There is a mazeed deal, ja den sogenannten Backstop, wäre deutlich besser für Nordirland politisch, vielleicht nicht wirtschaftlich, sondern politisch, aber das war nicht wirtschaftlich akzeptabel
für die konservative Parteien für Konservative Wähler. Also dieses Kernproblem, ja? Es heißt der Brexit triammer.
Also, was will man? Wo will man einfach die Grenze? Man hat drei Optionen.
Grenze in Irland ist für die EU nie akzeptabel. Grenze zwischen Nordeland und den Rest von Großbritannien.
Das ist, was wir fankisch jetzt haben, ja, diese Kontrollen an den für Waren, an den Fähren zwischen England und und und Nodien.
Das ist politisch ein Problem für notirischen Juniisten. Oder.
Nirgendwo eine Grenze, was man vorher hatte. Ja, freie Warenverkehr, aber das bedeutet, eine so sanften Brexit,
Das wäre dann politische und akzeptabel für die konservativen,
Also aber das wäre dann die Brexit-Lösung a la Three The May, ja, eine sanftere Brexit, um wenige Probleme in Nordirland zu verursachen. Und das ist, was wir jetzt beobachten.
Britische Regierung hat dieses wo muss die Grenze sein.
Einfach wie ich akzeptiert. Was tut die EU dagegen? Die haben die haben so gesagt okay,
Wir finden pragmatische Lösungen, um alles besser zu ermöglichen
Statt die Warner eine Grenze zu kontrollieren, wir führen eine zu anderen pragmatischen Systemen ein, einen sogenannten Programm, wenn einer eine, sagen wir so, ein Supermarkt sich in dieses
dieses System einträgt, die können einfach elektronisch
beweisen. In dieser Lieferung gab's XY. Das ist an diesen Supermärkten in Nordirland destiniert. Es wird nicht über die Grenze zu Irland gehen.
Kein Problem. Ja, so wir finden technische Lösungen für manche Problemen. Aber manche Problemen kann man halt nicht lösen. Ja, so eine eine Grenze und manche manche Kontrolle wird sich ja noch geben.
Aber dann, dass es dann ein den Grund für dieses.
Streit. Ja, also das es ist in den Interessen von London zu beweisen, dass die jetzige Situation in Nordirland nicht funktioniert,
obwohl es wirklich wirklich wirtschaftlich sehr gut funktioniert. Es ist es ist es ist nicht politisch funktioniert.
Da wollte ich nämlich jetzt nochmal drauf äh kommen, um das mal äh festzuhalten. Also wir haben jetzt diverse Probleme in Großbritannien beschrieben.
Abwasser, Landwirtschaft, Pipapo, LKW-Fahrer, keine dieser Probleme.
Gibt es in Nordirland, also da gibt's genug Fahrer, da gibt's genug Benzin, dann funktionieren die Klärwerke, die.
Wirtschaftlich ist in Ordnung. Die haben auch ähm äh diese neue Fähre Verbindungen äh zwischen Ross Leer direkt nach Frankreich eingeführt, um einfach so Großbritannien so umschiffen ähm.
Nur eine, sondern.
Mehren, ja, ja, nach es kommt ja noch so so eins nach sogar nach. Das klingt ein bisschen unlogisch, ja, aber irgendwie,
Die irische Regierung hat pragmatische, praktische Lösungen einfach gefunden. Die solche Lösungen sind für,
Die britische Regierung, die kommen einfach nicht in Frage. Ja? Und natürlich man will nicht als LKW-Fahrer.
Nicht mehr von Dublin nach Holly her, dann Dusch Großbritannien fahren zu müssen, in den Riesenstau stehen an äh an der Hafen von Dover, um dann einfach dann Frankreich zu erreichen. Es ist ja einfacher, obwohl 15 Stunden in einer Fähre nicht so besonders bequem ist. Es ist wirtschaftlich sinnvoller, sowas zu machen als durch Großbritannien zu fahren.
Ach so, unbequem ist das für die Fahrer jetzt, glaube ich, nicht. Ich meine, die.
Ja, im im Herbst, im Herbst beim Sturm, jetzt im auf dem Kanal, das ist nicht so mein Ding.
Na ja gut, dann muss man denn vielleicht die Betten mal, keine Ahnung, Wasserbetten oder so oder so was.
Ähm aber aber aber ehrlich. Die wirtschaftlichen Probleme gibt's ja derzeit einfach weniger in nur in Irland, als in dem Rest von Großbritannien.
Ja, auch das war alles äh vorhergesagt, dass es letzten Endes dazu führen kann. Ich frage mich jetzt auch grade, wenn.
Also das, dass das Aufkommen stärker werden von Schimpfen. Äh ist ja wiederum in der Republik
Irland wird das ja jetzt auch nicht jetzt so positiv gesehen
weil die halt auch ein bisschen Hardcore äh drauf sind und ähm in gewisser Hinsicht natürlich auch das das relativ stabile
politische System in Großbritannien äh in in äh in Irland. Äh durcheinander bringen würden, wo's ja immer so eine Balance ist. Wesentlich inzwischen zwei,
Parteien wenn ich das richtig erinnere ne? Genau wie schätzt du das jetzt ein? Haben wir schon ein paar Mal drüber gesprochen wenn dieser Trend sich so fortsetzt, dass die Nordiren sich ja eigentlich dran gewöhnen so,
Also im Prinzip hat ja England hat so die Brücken äh abgebrannt.
Nordirland hat ja schon immer auch eine eigene Identität äh gehabt und äh
ganz anderes Verhältnis auch zur Geschichte. Denkst du, dass die Leute sich jetzt im Rahmen des äh dieser Brexit-Auswirkungen dann auch einfach mental von Großbritannien,
also auch die, die eigentlich so traditionell dieses äh Verhältnis bevorzugt haben, dass das so.
Es gibt zwei Arten von Reaktionen. Manche Unionisten sagen, London hat uns einfach.
Ignoriert oder nicht respektiert? Wir sind auch ein Teil von Großbritannien, ja?
Und sehen, okay das ist diese fehlende Respekt führt dann so eine.
Okay, vielleicht ist es doch nicht so schlimm, wenn wir eine etwas engere Verbindung mit Dublin haben. Also,
ziehen daraus eine pragmatischere Schlussfolgerung. Ja, auf der anderen Seite,
Rhetorik von so Hardcore Unionisten wird immer extremer, also die DUP,
verliert ja Stimmen ah noch es gibt zwei oder drei andere noch extremere Parteien.
Die wollen einfach mal so wie wir verteidigen Not ihr Land noch mehr. Also die wollen dann noch stärker beweisen in London. Hey Moment mal, wir sind ein Teil von.
Großbritannien ja noch.
Aber zur Zeit dieses sehr starken unionistischen Parteien die kriegen insgesamt nur so 20 bis 25 Prozent der Unterstützung in Nordirland. So das bedeutet es.
Nicht alles führt zu einer.
Ein verreinigtes Irland. Es kurzfristig zu ein neu aufgestellte Diskussion in Nordirland. Statt zweiteilig dreiteilig,
Ja, also einfach Union ist ein,
und Unabhängigen dazwischen, also diese Alleinspart, also diesen unabhängigen Partei, ja die wollen pragmatische Lösungen, die sind nicht mit einer religiöse Gruppe gebunden.
Wollen kein Vereinigtes Irland, aber die wollen auch keine Grenze in Irland zwischen Nordirland und Republik. Also,
Das bedeutet, dass man Mustern mit einer komplett andere Situation in Nordirlandern rächen und was für Antworten hat.
London hat Johnson hat Forst. Die haben ja keine Antworten. Die haben ja kein Interesse. Die haben hier kein Verständnis. Ja also die spielen mit Feuer.
Aber wissen ja nicht, dass die dass es dass alles so richtig schief gehen könnte. Die haben kein Konzept, die haben ja keine Idee von wie könnte es.
Aussehen. Weil wenn die tun ja, was die dann die sagen, was die was die dann machen wollen, ist diese.
Ähm Artikel 16 verwenden. Ja, einfach mal das ist so eine Art Notbremse in den Vertrag zwischen die EU.
Wenn irgendwas schief läuft.
Im im Falle von ja, es ist nicht definiert, was ist, ja? Wenn es für so Schwierigkeiten,
das das Großbritannien könnte Kontrollen.
In den Warenverkehr zwischen Irland und Notirland dann einführen. Also man könnte dann was wirtschaftlich zur Zeit gut funktioniert.
Von einem Tag bis den nächsten kaputt machen. Also wirtschaftlichen Schaden,
aber in den politischen Interessen von notirischen Junioristen. Also David,
Wäre bereit vielleicht so was dann zu machen. Aber das bringe dann eine Art äh ich weiß nicht, wie man das auf Deutsch sagt.
Also deine Gegenreaktion so, ja. Ähm.
Bestrafung, also.
Bestrafung von der EU, ja? Also dann Maßnahmen von der EU-Seite gegen Großbritannien.
Vergeltung ist das richtige Wort, ne?
Das führt dann.
Dann zurück in die komplette Krise, was wir dann schon äh so am Anfang von dem Podcast debattiert haben.
Großbritannien ist schon in eine schwierige Situation, in den Handelsbeziehungen mit der Rest der EU.
Also wäre es sinnvoll, aus politischen Gründen in Not ihr Land, um den notirischen Junioristen so ein bisschen.
Politisches Stärkung zu geben, einfach einen Handelsstreit mit der EU auszulösen. Unter den jetzigen Umständen wäre so was verrückt.
Ja, total.
Aber das ist, das ist ja die jetzige Richtung von von Forst. Ja, er steuert auf so einen Kurs Konfrontation mit der EU,
um die Union ist eine Nordehran ein bisschen so blitsches Rückenwind zu geben. Sowas wäre.
Total außer in pragmatischen Sicht total sinnlos. Aber das ist wohl auch grad steuert.
Ja okay, das kann ja trotzdem passieren. Ich habe gerade überlegt, ähm ich weiß, es ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig, diese ganzen Unabhängigkeits äh diskussionen, aber ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass ich in Nordirland dann ja vielleicht mit dieser Partei
auch nochmal so eine neue
politische Perspektive auftun könnte, so langfristig, dass die Entscheidung in Nordirland ja immer im Raum steht durch das Karfreitags äh Abkommen hat ja Nordirland quasi das Recht zu sagen
Wollen wir zu Irland gehören oder wollen wir zu Großbritannien gehören? Dann die dritte Variante ist eigentlich ja so nie diskutiert worden. Was wäre denn, wenn sozusagen Nordirland unabhängig wird.
Ja oder so eine Art Sonderstatus. Ja, ähm äh es wäre oder oder das ist, was man.
Fuck the Show oder wirtschaftlich schon hart.
Es ist ja schon da, ne.
Ja, ja. Ähm aber natürlich man brauche dann irgendeine andere politische Lösung, weil auch was.
Äh also die demokratischen Institutionen in Nordirland sind nicht.
Stabil grade, ja? Also dass das so eine Art eigene Staat zu gründen, ja? So, ist diese jetzige Kompromiss, was man zurzeit hat.
Jetzt wirklich so schwierig zu zu gestalten, nicht so unbedingt.
Mittelfristig könnte ich schwierige werden, wenn größte Partei wird nach der Wahl. Also das ist ein bisschen.
Die Hoffnung in London, ja, also wäre es noch möglich, dass die Junioristen doch noch halbwegs gewinnen könnten, ja?
Aber aus meiner Sicht im einzigen Weg sowas zu ermöglichen, wäre.
Wirklich pragmatische Lösungen zu finden, den Alltags ermöglichen, den die Unterstützung,
Von dir Lions Party zu zu entziehen, ja, das alltägliche Leben für Menschen in nur dir lang pragmatisch.
Pragmatische Lösung für die praktischen Probleme zu finden. Start so sehr ideologisch auf Konfrontation zu steuern. Aber das ist was, was was man gerade tut. Ja, aber mittelfristig, ich fürchte, dass.
Ich sehe kein vereinigtes Irland mittelfristig. Es ist ja so schwierig. Es ist auch nicht unbedingt in Dublin erwünscht.
Und keinen oder vielleicht sogar eine irgendeine ungewöhnliche Sondestatus. Eine eine weite Führung von Feindlich, was man gerade hat. Ist wahrscheinlich.
Ja, gar nicht gesprochen haben wir jetzt über Schottland. Ähm auch da äh nähern sich ja ein paar äh Deadlines.
Prinzip ist die Situation ja unverändert, die.
SNP hat bei den letzten Wahlen ja sehr stark äh abgeschlossen. Ich weiß nicht, hatten wir vor oder nach den Wahlen.
Knapp nach der Wahl, also.
Am Ende der es fehlte eine Mehrheit für den von ein oder zwei Sitzen, also die Regierung jetzt zusammen mit den Grünen, die auch für für einen unabhängigen Schottland sind.
Alles ist zur Zeit entsprechend ruhig. Ähm,
Fleischaufwahl, COP sechsundzwanzig in Schortland stattfindet, also ein bisschen äh ähm Nickel Stergen will, keinen zusätzliches Streit äh auslösen, ähm.
Und die die Schoki-Regierung stand auch unter Druck wegen Corona. Ähm also,
trotz etwas strengere Regeln in in Schottland,
Todesraten und und Druck auf den Gesundheitssystem. War fast genauso hoch in Schottland wie in den Rest von Großbritannien. Also.
Ich habe den Eindruck gekriegt, dass die sich ein bisschen so so gehalten in den in den letzten Monaten. Wir werden mal sehen, ob es so bleibt. Äh nächstes Jahr. Also ich denke, dass.
Die jetzt so verstanden einfach so.
Einfach so auf eine Kursunabhängigkeit zu steuern, wären es aussieht, dass Großbritannien steckt in einer so in einer Gesundheitskrise, in einer Pandemie und zum Teil in eine plüschige Krise. Vielleicht ist das nicht.
So klug,
Ähm also die Debatte fand nicht so Unabhängigkeit fand nicht so statt in den letzten Monaten. Also die die die Tatsachen bleiben grob unverändert.
Aber trotzdem war ja die Ankündigung im Raum, dass man das äh Referendum fürs nächste Jahr oder 23 weiß gar nicht.
Nächstes Jahr oder 23, aber wir haben wir haben immer noch kein Klarheit. Ist das überhaupt,
juristisch möglich oder nicht, weil.
Vorher aus als die das so 214 Referendum ähm gemacht haben. Man man hat da damals die Zusage von ähm von Cameron und von von London.
Dich riecht. Und es ist es ist,
umstritten, ob dann eine Zusage braucht, um überhaupt so eine Referendum,
auszuführen. Ähm also da haben wir immer noch kein Klarheit.
Ähm also das bleibt das bleibt ja offen. Wäre es möglich für die Schotten zu einer so eine indikatives Volksabstimmung durchzuführen könntet so was dann so ein Punkt,
kommen, wie, wie, wie in Katalonien. Ähm sowas, was dann braucht, ist den Eindruck, dass alles in London.
Halbwegs ruhig, ein halbwegs stabil ist und sie kann dann, okay, das ist unser Plan für ein Referendum, dann die Regierung dann vorstellen und wir werden dann mal sehen,
wie wir reagiert dann Johnson und äh und und Govensau. Aber dieses Punkt haben wir bisher nicht erreicht und das.
Vermute ich werden wir nicht erreichen dieses Jahr. So, im Frühling nächstes Jahr vielleicht, wenn alles hoffentlich auch in in Sachen Pandemiebekämpfung alles entsprechend.
Ruhiger geworden ist.
Ja, jetzt haben wir eigentlich alles durch, ähm was vorhin ja aber auch noch mal den aktuellen Fall, der grade diskutiert wird um Korruption
äh angesprochen, das ist ja auch ein generelles Problem äh mit dieser Regierung. Also das äh ist ja
nicht der erste Fall, der jetzt hier äh bekannt geworden ist und normalerweise grät aber immer kein Hahn danach, weil's irgendwie da was, sei es irgendwas neues, äh bekannt geworden, was man nicht schon längst kennt.
Ging schon bedingt. Also es gibt diese unabhängige Prozedere um Korruptionsfälle und Abgeordneten zu untersuchen. Und natürlich die Konservativen haben.
So äh haben immer gegen diese Prozederen gekämpft. Äh die,
Die wollen keine keine Kontrollen, Nebeneinkünfte für Abgeordneten sind deutlich höher unter Konservativen als unter Labour Abgeordneten. Wir haben da ein bisschen das Gleiche in Deutschland beobachtet, dass es so,
CDU Abgeordneten haben dann diverse Lobbyeinkünfte neben Einkünfte.
Sehr interessant ist, ist die diese der gestern zurückgetreten ist und und vorgestern ähm.
So unter Druck stand.
So Riesennebeneinkumte und hat dann dann Lobbyarbeit für diese diese Firmen auch auch gemacht. Es sogar eine ehemaliger Minister für Not Irland sogar, eine sehr starke Brexiteerin Patterson.
Der da irgendwie nicht verstanden, dass so was gefährlich sein könnte für die Konservativen. Die Konservativen haben sogar abgestimmt im Britischen Unterhaus, einfach mal um die Regeln zu ändern, um um Puttersonce zu schützen.
Das löst es so eine enorme Kritik aus, dass am Tag danach Boris Johnson dazu gesagt hat, hey Moment mal, also vielleicht machen wir das doch nicht, so ein U-Turn von einem Tag bis in den nächsten.
Und dann ist selbst als Abgeordnete dann so getreten. Also was es muss dann einen Nachwahl geben in in seinen Wahlkreis, in Not, ähm.
Das ist einfach den Politikern politischen Alltag. Also,
Es gibt ja Diskussionen in Großbritannien. Es es ging nicht unbedingt um Partison, sondern um Boris Johnson selbst. Weil die haben, wo er wo er wohnt, in Downingstreet, finanziert und wir wissen nicht, wer das finanziert hat. Das kam
nicht aus staatlichen Gelder, so dieses ähm diese Wohnung, was was Johnson und und äh Carry ähm ähm wo die dann wohnen,
Die Bearbeitungskosten kamen nicht aus öffentlichen Fonds. Ja, weil das was für eine so eine Sulux seriöse Umbau der,
Wohnung in Downingstreet.
Scheint ja sehr.
Da scheint ja eine Frage zu sein, aus welchen Fällen kamen diese Finanzen?
Ähm also das war dann ein bisschen ja so diese Diskussion diese Woche. Ging das wirklich um um Partison selbst,
oder um Johnson. Ja und und Johnson versuchte dann diese Überwachungskontrollgremium zu enthüllen,
um sich selbst zu schützen. Es es war äh also passt es ein selbst war nicht so dem dem Fall. Ähm.
Willkommen mal wieder zu dem zu dem Kernpunkt zurück.
Wie wichtig ist das in die alltägliche Politikdebatte in Großbritannien? Dass die Konservativen sehen.
Korrupt aus,
Wir haben so viele Korruptionsfälle gesehen in Großbritannien letzten Monaten. Besonders bei den Beschaffungen von dem ähm wäre und Corona. Die Verträge gingen an Freunden von Diverser diverser Abgeordnete.
Es gibt ja ähm diverse juristische Fälle, laufen gerade Korruptionsuntersuchungen. Aber.
Das wirkt nur, wenn es eine faktische, tatsächliche Auswirkung hat.
Auf die Partei und auf die Umfragewerte.
Wenn das kein wenn es kein gibt und die Leute sehen, okay Laybo oder die Liberalen oder weiß nicht wem, irgendwie.
Weniger korrupt sind, dann beginnt dann eine Überlegung bei den Konservativen.
Etwas ein bisschen anders zu machen.
Aber was sehr wichtig war, letzte Woche mit diese ganze Diskussion über die äh Abwasserbearbeitung und diese Woche, die über die ganze Diskussion zu dem Thema.
Haben einfach so eine komplette Umdrehung der Positionen.
Von einem Tag bis den nächsten gemacht. Abwasser war, oh wir haben ein Problem.
Am Tag danach, oh nee, sorry, ja, wir haben doch ein Problem. Wir leiten keine Reduktion der Umweltstandards ein. Von einem Tag bis den nächsten,
Diese Woche haben wir gesehen, am Mittwoch, ja okay, wir enden die Regeln damit Orient Patterson Abgeordnete bleiben kann.
Gestern war schon ein Bus zurücktreten. Ja so es ist so eine komplette Ehre, ja und es die verrückteste Fall war, war ein so ein Staatssekretärin, so ein Junior Minister.
Am Mittwoch tat die Frau zurück, weil sie wollte nicht.
Dass die Regierung wirft die Regeln übers Board um um um Partison also unterstützen,
hat sie selbst als Ministerin oder Staatssekretärin so selbst darüber getreten. Am Donnerstag war sie dann so, weil die Regierung die Position komplett geendet hatte. Ja? Es ist.
Man hat den Eindruck, dass.
Tollhaus ist das.
Das wer hat alles im Griff? Niemand hat alles im Griff. Ja also irgendwie ja so diese berühmte Exitweise Dominic Comings ja,
war vielleicht manchmal verrückt. Der war vielleicht manchmal böse, aber der hatte irgendein Strategie. Der hat alles dem kompletten Downing Street Communication und und und Richtung,
hat er halbwegs im Griff. Wer kontrolliert?
Diese ganze Situation ja gerade, ja? Es gab in der Financial Times heute Vormittag die Situation. Äh oh oder ein Zitat aus Quellen in der Nähe von Boris Johnson. Boris Johnson sei genervt,
von Owen Patterson, dass er irgendwie wie gravierend diese Situation war,
nicht hatte, nicht kapiert.
Er hat dieses Fall von Anfang an, ja, nicht kapiert. Was passierte, ist vor zwei Jahren geschehen?
Er hat kein einziges Mal. Jemals gesagt, ich habe,
ein Fehler gemacht. Hat er nicht akzeptiert, Punkt. Wie kann es dann passieren, dass Boris schon sagt, ja, ich finde es ein bisschen komisch, dass er seinen Fehler nicht akzeptiert hatte. Hatte es seit 2 Jahren nicht.
Also irgendwie Downing Street hat die komplette politische.
Professionalität komplett verloren. Ja, es ist so die Agieren von einem Tag bis in den nächsten.
Und es hat keine reale Auswirkung, weil die bleiben ja weit vor Labeln im Meinungsumfragen. Es ist die Saison.
Ist kaputt gegangen. Wenn man etwas faktisch schlecht macht, was für Auswirkungen hat das?
Zur Zeit, man hat ihn eingeholt, dass alles wird schlechter, aber ohne Auswirkungen für die Konservativen.
Äh und wie lang kann das weitergehen? Ja, es ist die große, offene Frage.
Ja, ändert einen so ein bisschen auch an die Trump äh Regierung, die in ihrem Stil noch ein bisschen unerträglicher war, aber es hat auch schön äh Züge davon. Und ich meine, ist ja auch in Deutschland oft so, dass man sich auch fragt so, warum
haben einfach bestimmte politische Handlungen keine Konsequenzen, ne? Ich meine, haben wir ja nun in der letzten Regierung auch eine ganze Menge Skandale gehabt und auch eine sehr geringe
Bereitschaft äh zurückzutreten. Das ist ja schon so ein bisschen auch so ein Trend, ne, so nach diesem Motto, och wieso, das sitzen wir einfach aus.
Probieren einfach mal was geht so. Wir gucken einfach mal, wie lange man denn äh äh Oberwasser behalten kann und zeigt sich
mal so die moralische Notbremse gar nicht so schnell ziehen muss, sondern das einfach so ja nö man geht einfach nicht weg und ja macht auch was dagegen, klagt doch irgendwie äh das macht dann irgendwie keiner und äh ja dann
dann ist es halt irgendwann auch einfach akzeptiert, weil die Öffentlichkeit auch gar nicht mehr in der Lage ist, diesen politischen Prozess irgendwie nennenswert zu folgen
Was sicherlich auch ein Problem der Gesamtkonstellation medialer Aufmerksamkeit,
Also worauf stürzen sich Medien eigentlich.
Für Vertrauen in das komplette System
ist so gering. Also so besonders sei der der der Parlamentier Expense Skandal 2008, also ähm Vertrauen in wie Abgeordneten agieren oder wie die aus Menschen,
arbeiten ist so gering in Großbritannien. Das es ist irgendwie ja natürlich könnte man,
Eine Frage stellen, ist sind die Konservativen korrupter als Labour? Man findet bestimmt in die Bevölkerung heraus. Ja, die sind ja kobter. Aber das ist ein bisschen ja, das ist eine eine Entscheidung zwischen Pest und Cholera.
Ja, also einfach, beide sind schlecht, nur die Konservativen sind einen Tick schlechter. Ja, also das hilft Laber nicht oder anderen Parteien nicht.
Irgendwas so dagegen zu tun. Ja wir sind nicht korrupt. Ja aber wenn wenn.
Wenn die innerhalb der Bewölkerung den Eindruck herrscht, dass alle korrupt sind, hat man das dann,
Das hat dann keine Auswirkungen, wenn die Konservativen besonders grob sind.
Das ist die jetzige Situation, zumindest meine meine Wahrnehmung.
John.
Optimistisches.
Das war's jetzt eigentlich bisher auch noch nie. Das ist glaube ich auch so ein bisschen dieser verführerische Reiz dieser Serie, dass man eigentlich, wie du schon am Anfang gesagt hast, ne? Also man man schaut so einem Car-Crash in Zeitlupe zu und ähm
jetzt grade noch dabei, wie äh der Wagen in der Luft sich so dreht und anfängt sich zu überschlagen, aber ist noch nicht noch nicht wieder aufgekommen.
Ich finde das meine die Situation ist so.
Schwierig. Ich wünsche riesige Proteste. Wirklich. Also das ist.
Also gar nichts anderes funktioniert. Ja also nationalen Streiks oder Millionen Leute auf der Straße und irgendwas.
Also, die normalen Wegen funktionieren halt nicht.
Parlamentarische Opposition funktioniert nicht,
was in in Interviews abläuft oder so funktioniert nicht. Also ein weder,
akzeptieren diese neue Situation sagen, okay, das sind die Auswirkungen des Brexits. Das ist diese neue Nummer, ja? Also mit alles, was es bringt.
Oder man muss irgendeine andere Opposition irgendwie halbwegs gründen, ja?
Ähm schau mal, was die in keine Ahnung in der Ukraine oder in Serbien oder so für Bürgerbewegungen ins Laufen gebracht haben. Das ist die einzige Hoffnung zur Zeit.
Ja, aber man hat trotzdem den Eindruck, dass einfach das britische Volk sich das so ein bisschen entwöhnt hat. Also es ist einfach, man ist zu lange, zu ähm
zu gut gefahren auch, ich meine ein Land und das Problem haben wir natürlich auch in Deutschland in gewisser Hinsicht, ne. Was sich auch so an seinen eigenen Reichtum so sehr gewöhnt hat
dass man überhaupt gar nicht mehr in der Lage ist, so aus den eigenen Reihen heraus, die wirklich,
kritischen die Essential Walker zu bedienen, ja und,
Wie gesagt, das sehe ich ja hier auch als ein Problem, ja. Würden wir hier die Grenzen zumachen für ausländische äh Mitarbeiter. Hier würde sofort auch alles komplett
umkippen, weil du einfach aus der deutschen Bevölkerung heraus die kritischen Berufe nicht mehr bestückt bekommst.
Natürlich ein bisschen damit zu tun hat, dass sich eben dieses Klassendenken äh auch nicht so richtig aus den Gesellschaften verabschiedet hat und das ist ja in Großbritannien auch nochmal viel
extremer, ja
wollen alle halt so kleine Königinnen äh sein und äh so die ähm hat sich in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon mit einem gewissen Wohlstand.
Gefunden. Klar, die sind natürlich auch noch mit,
drin und so, aber eben nicht ausreichend, um das ganze System zu tragen, was natürlich den Grund hat, dass das System als solches
diese wichtige Arbeit nicht ausreichend belohnt und nicht ausreichend wertschätzt und nicht dafür sorgt, dass eben diese starken Unterschiede in der Gesellschaft,
aufgelöst oder zumindest angeglichen werden, ne. Und ähm ja, jetzt zeigt sich eben schön, dass wenn man von heute auf morgen diesen Ausweg über das Ausland, ja, äh wählt, ja und was ja im Prinzip bedeutet,
Europa ist ja eigentlich ein Land mittlerweile.
Will nicht jeder so sehen und natürlich gibt's da auch Probleme damit, aber de facto rechtlich ist es so, wir sind jetzt ein Wirtschaftsgebiet und wir sind in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein
politischer Raum, der zwar extrem zisseliert und kleinteilig äh äh ist und wo es doch viel Hickhack und Unterschiede gibt und wo wir generell auch noch lange, lange Zeit dieses Problem haben werden, dass wir einfach unterschiedliche stark unterschiedliche Kulturregionen sind mit einer anderen Sprache, mit anderer
Wertschätzung mit anderen äh Auffassungen in Bezug auf Religion, Kultur, Gesellschaft
alles Mögliche, aber auch das ist letzten Endes eine Frage äh der Zeit. In dem Moment, wo man sich aus diesem Land einfach verabschiedet und sagt so, ah ja, nee, wir wollen, dass alles so bleibt, wie es ist, aber wir wollen trotzdem gleichzeitig alles ändern. Das funktioniert halt einfach nicht mehr.
Und wir merken auch, dass die Strukturen,
Ja, es werden immer Spannungen geben zwischen europäische Länder. Aber die EU bietet uns ein Struktur an, um diese Probleme nach einem ordentlichen Art und Weise halbwegs zu lösen.
Großbritannien hat all das über Bord geworfen und jetzt haben diese dauerhafte Streitepunkte zwischen Großbritannien und die EU ohne Einstruktur bisher, die überhaupt sie lösen.
Ja?
Das Europäische Parlament hat so eine british ins Leben gerufen. Theoretisch mit die Beteiligung von Abgeordneten aus dem Europäischen Parlament und aus Abgeordneten aus dem Brit hinunter aus und aus Lord.
Briten haben bisher keine keine Mitglieder dafür nominiert. Also wollen sich nicht daran beteiligen. Ja, also.
Diese Strukturen müssen wir erneut.
So erfinden und das ist, was auch dann auf der britischen Seite mich so stört, ist in Deutschland, in Frankreich, in die EU.
Wie institutionen unsere Politik,
so gestalten und prägen und limitieren, was es auch sehr wichtig ist. Ja und die diversen Ebenen und wie man regelt diese Probleme äh Zwischenebenen.
Diese Strukturen sind in Großbritannien verdammt schwach, ja? So, das,
London bereit ist, ein Teil des Landes, Feindlich zu ignorieren so jahrelang, wie London in Nordirland ignoriert hat, ja?
Wäre es möglich in Deutschland juristisch so wie politisch, keine Ahnung, Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, komplett so ignorieren, ja total.
Ginge ja nicht,
nach dieser Art und Weise. Und irgendwie, das ist auch so ein Blindpunkt in der ja, Großbritannien ist eine Demokratie, es war jahrelang so ist eins von den ältsten Demokratien der Welt und so weiter und so fort, bla, bla.
Nee, Moment mal.
Das hat so gezeigt, wie schwach die Situation in Großbritannien gerade ist, demokratisch. Und dass die Strukturen sind vielleicht nicht gar so stabil wie man vorher,
Gedacht hat, ja? Das alles war so auf dem Basis von ungeschriebene Regeln,
dass niemanden tut, was wenn die dann in der Zukunft, in der Opposition wären,
ja? Ja, man respektiert die Oppositionsparteien heutzutage, weil morgen man könnte selbst in die Opposition sein,
Das gilt nicht so wirklich mir, ja? Ähm und und dieses, das ist, was mir so,
so stört. Und wenn man sieht, dieses so, dieses Blatt in Großbritannien, Respekt hat, so eine Art,
Fokusartige Plat für für für Konservative Leute, ja, so einer kommt einmal der Woche raus, das war eine Debattenzeitschrift,
für für für Leute auf den rechten Flügel das will ich nicht und der Herausgeber Frazi Nails ne also ich sagte immer.
Ja, wenn wir blechen nach Europa
äh die haben ja diese ähm diese Rechtsextremisten, also Le Pen oder Alternative für Deutschland oder Probleme mit Justice in Polen und so weiter. Das haben wir hier solange in Großbritannien glücklicherweise nie und haben wir nie gehabt,
Ja? Nie diese Menschen sind,
innerhalb der Regierung in Großbritannien, die haben, was die dann tun, die was die in Sache Medienfreiheit und Unabhängigkeit oder oder äh der Regierung machen. Das ist was wie was Orban macht in Ungarn,
Aber die Brücken kapieren das nicht. Das kann in Groß mit Hanni nicht passieren in so eine alte altes, demokratisches Land. Nein, das passiert vor unserer Augen.
Und das ist dann mit Blick aus Deutschland und das ist, was ich so so wichtig macht, so wichtig ist, warum wir diese Art dieser Diskussion führen und Social Podcast machen.
Ist, wenn man Deutschland versteht oder Frankreich versteht oder die EU versteht und man blickt nach Großbritannien.
Dann hat man eine komplett andere Perspektive, was die meisten, die nur Bridges Port Sie jeweils gemacht haben. Diese Perspektive haben diese Menschen einfach nicht,
Und das ist, warum dann aus meinem Begonnen, worum es dann so schiefgehen kann, ohne dass die meisten Menschen in Großbritannien das wirklich ca.
Das äh das sehe ich ganz genauso.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie ich das besser äh beenden sollte heute. Ich denke, alles erstmal wieder zusammengefegt, alles gesagt zum äh Brexit und der Gesamtsituation.
Wir bleiben dran. Ja. Und ähm mal gucken, wann äh wieder genug passiert ist, dass.
Ja ja. Riesenproteste im Podium nächstes Jahr. Können wir hoffen.
Ja, wenn's das gibt. Das wäre ja mal was. Das wäre ja mal was. Okay, dann sage ich, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören bei UKW. Ähm.
Geht's weiter mit irgendwas demnächst wieder und Brexit äh auch wieder irgendwann. Bis dahin sage.